Hey guys, this is, welcome back. This is the first time, this is the first time I've done this that we're doing the show since we made the, well, no, we made a, didn't we make a blood pact? I mean, did we not, not that I know of? Did we not make a blood pack? Who did I make a blood pact with? Oh, no. I'll figure it out later. All right.
嘿，伙计们，我是，欢迎回来。这是我第一次，这是我第一次做这件事，自从我们做了，嗯，不，我们做了一个，我们不是做了一个血盟吗？我是说，我们难道没有吗？据我所知没有？我们难道没有立下血盟吗？我和谁立了血盟？哦，不。我以后再弄清楚。好吧。
In the meantime, let's go to all news form. I love it. Smart. Hey, you know, J.B., somebody said to me the other day, you've become like the Jack Nicholson of the Dodgers. Oh, yeah. You're at the Dodgers. You're on the broadcast.
在此期间，让我们进入所有新闻形式。我喜欢它。聪明。嘿，你知道，J.B.，前几天有人对我说，你已经变得像道奇队的杰克·尼科尔森了。哦，是的。你在道奇队。你在广播里。
What a high compliment. I know, I know. And, Shawnee, you were there with them, and the guys were like, somebody said that the guys were like, hey, there's two-thirds of the smart list crew, and where's our money? We had such a joy.
多高的赞美啊。我知道，我知道。而且，肖尼，你和他们在一起，那些家伙就像，有人说那些家伙就像，嘿，这是聪明名单团队的三分之二，我们的钱在哪里？我们真是太开心了。
I mean, Willie, if I had three tickets. I know, sure, sure. This was last week, it was dinner. This week, it's the game. I mean, most people would be like, hey. And, Sean, we're still good for Rome, right? Yeah. Oh, this is what it is.
我是说，威利，如果我有三张票。我知道，当然，当然。这是上周，是晚餐。这周，是比赛。我是说，大多数人会说，嘿。而且，肖恩，我们去罗马的计划还算数，对吧？是的。哦，这就是它的样子。
This is a, you're getting me back. for all the holidays that Sean and I went on. I mean, the stamps on your passports. No, we missed you, Willie. We really did have a nice time, didn't we, Shawnee? Oh, my God. It was so easy, breezy. We haven't done that in ever.
这是一个，你在报复我。为了肖恩和我去过的所有假期。我是说，你护照上的印章。不，我们想念你，威利。我们真的度过了一段美好的时光，不是吗，肖尼？哦，天哪。真是太轻松、太惬意了。我们从来没那样做过。
And, you know, it reminded me, Willie, of, I took you to the, was it game one of the World Series last year when Freddie Freeman hit that walk off Grand Slam? How good was that? We were jumping around, like what was the last game contest uh the last game of what is that where is that was that the famous last game last year where it was the last game i believe it was the first game it was the first game and it was a world series yeah where he just like got a bases loaded home run like yeah and then
而且，你知道，这让我想起了，威利，我带你去，是去年世界大赛的第一场比赛吗，当时弗雷迪·弗里曼打出了那个再见满贯？那有多棒？我们跳来跳去，就像最后一场比赛是什么，最后一场比赛是什么，那是哪里，那是去年著名的最后一场比赛吗，那是最后一场比赛，我相信那是第一场比赛，那是第一场比赛，那是世界大赛，是的，他就像打出了满垒本垒打，就像是的，然后
the series continued for the uh the yankees to go ahead and they kind of dropped the ball on the whole series get it Yankee fans will know that pun oh gosh well you just you alienated 50 million people so Listen, the yanks are going to get another chance. Well, who knows when this is going to air? But it seems like they might get a good chance. I also look at what I just fucking did, like five minutes before we came on. Playing with the dog outside and I ran inside and I fucking tripped over him. And to break my fall, I grabbed the door.
系列赛继续进行，洋基队领先，他们在整个系列赛中有点掉链子，明白吗，洋基队的球迷会明白这个双关语，哦天哪，好吧，你疏远了5000万人，所以听着，洋基队还会再有机会的。好吧，谁知道这什么时候播出？但看起来他们可能会有很好的机会。我也看看我刚才他妈的做了什么，就在我们上线前五分钟。在外面和狗玩，我跑进屋里，他妈的被他绊倒了。为了缓冲我的跌倒，我抓住了门。
And my fist finger went all the way back here. Oh, God. Really? Yeah, just like five minutes ago. I was like, oh. Wait, so you're on ice right now? Well, just in case, yeah. Well, luckily, no joke.
我的拳头手指一直向后弯到这里。哦，天哪。真的吗？是的，就在五分钟前。我当时想，哦。等等，所以你现在在冰敷吗？好吧，以防万一，是的。好吧，幸运的是，不开玩笑。
Luckily, you're done with the play. I know. Could you imagine? No. Couldn't play. Wouldn't be able to play. I know. Oh, that Ricky.
幸运的是，你已经演完了。我知道。你能想象吗？不。没法演。没法演。我知道。哦，那个瑞奇。
It would be good night Oscar if that were the case, you know. Incredible. Wait, Sean, why have you asked me and then my wife separately if my dogs are good with other dogs? Because I want to bring Ricky over, but I don't want to bring him if your dogs are going to attack. Why would you be bringing Ricky over? because I might come see a movie this weekend. Okay. But you spend three hours plus over at Jens every week you don't bring Ricky.
如果是那样的话，奥斯卡就晚安了，你知道。不可思议。等等，肖恩，你为什么问我，然后又单独问我妻子，我的狗和其他狗相处得好吗？因为我想带瑞奇过去，但如果你的狗要攻击它，我不想带它去。你为什么要带瑞奇过去？因为我这周末可能会去看电影。好吧。但你每周在詹家待三个多小时，你都不带瑞奇。
Look at the judging face. I just don't understand like what's going on. Is Ricky having separation anxieties lately? No, no. It's just a thing as a dog owner. I just don't like to leave him alone for like three, four hours. Jamie, I would describe your face as a scowl right now. It's a scow.
看看那评判的脸。我只是不明白发生了什么。瑞奇最近有分离焦虑吗？不，不。这只是养狗人的事。我只是不喜欢把它单独留在那儿三、四个小时。杰米，我会形容你现在的表情是怒容。是怒容。
No, but I would like to bring him over to Jens, but they don't get along. Well, yeah, but. So I was like, oh, it's. if your dogs get along it'll be great i could just bring him over and if not by the way that's fine too but i but the bigger issue is why why do you and scotty feel like ricky needs so much constant like dogs can be left alone and by the way you just spent almost a full year out of the country i know i don't know how he fed himself he fed himself i don't know how he drove himself around listen this is going to be controversial but but we live in an era where people bring their dogs over to
不，但我确实想把它带到詹家，但它们相处得不好。好吧，是的，但是。所以我当时想，哦，这是。如果你的狗相处得好，那就太好了，我可以把它带过去，如果不行，顺便说一句，那也没关系，但我，但更大的问题是为什么，为什么你和斯科蒂觉得瑞奇需要这么多持续的，就像狗可以被单独留下，顺便说一句，你刚在国外待了几乎整整一年，我知道，我不知道它是怎么喂饱自己的，它喂饱了自己，我不知道它是怎么开车到处走的，听着，这会引起争议，但我们生活在一个人们经常把狗带到
other people's houses a lot and i don't i'm not judging you shan on this but people do it they And they were like, I got my dog with him. I'm like, what do you mean you got your dog with you? It's not okay. Yeah, and I'm a dog. I love dogs. I've had lots of dogs. I have a dog.
别人家里的时代，我不是在评判你，肖恩，但人们确实这么做，他们就像，我带着我的狗。我说，你带着你的狗是什么意思？这不合适。是的，我是一条狗。我喜欢狗。我养过很多狗。我有一条狗。
But you don't need to bring your dog with you when you go to somebody else's house. I like the dog. I'm not saying that you don't. Then continue having more morning playtime with them then. People show up, I got my dog with me. Oh, you've got your dog with you? What if everybody brought their dog everywhere? It would be mayhem.
但当你去别人家时，你不需要带上你的狗。我喜欢狗。我不是说你不喜欢。那就继续和它们进行更多的早晨玩耍吧。人们出现，我带着我的狗。哦，你带着你的狗？如果每个人都把狗带到任何地方会怎样？那将是一片混乱。
This is what I love. This is what I love to see. I'm a dog person. You must be a, you're a monster. Oh, sorry, he peed. Where are you paper towels? No, this is what I love. That's not what I'm going on.
这就是我喜欢的。这就是我喜欢看到的。我是个爱狗人士。你一定是个，你是个怪物。哦，抱歉，它尿了。纸巾在哪里？不，这就是我喜欢的。那不是我要说的。
I love the conversation that I know happened this morning and Jason's face as he was having it with Amanda. It was a couple days ago, and I've been really stewing on it. Sean, Amanda's like, Sean just texted me if our dogs are okay with other dogs. And you turn with your cup of coffee or just sludge, your cup of sludge. And I said, fucking what? By the way, you know where he is? He's in his chair, in his little study, with the fire going and he's watching MSNBC.
我喜欢我知道今天早上发生的对话，以及杰森和阿曼达谈话时的表情。那是几天前的事了，我一直在琢磨。肖恩，阿曼达说，肖恩刚给我发短信问我们的狗和其他狗相处得好吗。你转过身，拿着你的咖啡杯，或者只是污泥，你的污泥杯。我说，他妈的什么？顺便说一句，你知道他在哪吗？他在他的椅子上，在他的小书房里，开着火，正在看MSNBC。
And then he barely moves and he looks at her and she's at the door because she's too scared to come in because she sees the pre-scow. She knows the pre-scale. Who knows what stage of gummy he's at? You know what I mean? Yeah, I will scratch. He's afraid of dad. Yeah. You know?
然后他几乎不动，看着她，她站在门口，因为她太害怕不敢进来，因为她看到了预怒容。她知道预怒容。谁知道他处于什么阶段的口香糖？你知道我的意思吗？是的，我会抓挠。他怕爸爸。是的。你知道吗？
She does a very tentative little. Yeah, a little knock. Yeah. Sorry. Are you, sorry, are you not on commercial? Is it not commercial? I guess, I tell you what, tell you who's not tentative is our guest today.
她做了一个非常试探性的小动作。是的，轻轻敲了一下。是的。抱歉。你，抱歉，你不在广告时间吗？不是广告时间吗？我想，我告诉你谁不是试探性的，是我们今天的嘉宾。
Nice. Oh, let's get into it. Yeah. Uh, hang on a second. Check the, check the chat. Hang on in one second. Oh, yeah. Oh, by the way.
不错。哦，让我们开始吧。是的。呃，等一下。检查一下，检查一下聊天记录。等一下。哦，是的。哦，顺便说一句。
Yeah. Yeah, sorry, before we go, before we get into our guests who we want to talk to immediately. Yeah. Tickets to the Hollywood Bowl, November 15th. Oh. For Smartless live.
是的。是的，抱歉，在我们走之前，在我们进入我们想立即交谈的嘉宾之前。是的。好莱坞露天剧场的门票，11月15日。哦。为了聪明名单直播。
Wait, do I need to buy tickets for that? I'd really like to go to that. Do I need to buy tickets? No, we're giving you two cops. We're going to give you two comp. One for you and then plus one. I'd love a stage. I'd love a stage seat.
等等，我需要买票吗？我真的很想去。我需要买票吗？不，我们给你两张票。我们要给你两张赠票。一张给你，然后加一张。我想要一个舞台座位。我想要一个舞台座位。
If you have a stage seat. You go to smartlist.com slash live. So you go to smartlist.com slash live for the Hollywood Bowl show on the 15th of November. Guys, this is going to be, it's going to be very nerve-wracking for us. Because what are we doing up there at the Hollywood Bowl? We can barely do this. We're barely doing this. I will tell you that my guest is one of our biggest stars in the movie industry.
如果你有舞台座位。你去smartlist.com斜杠live。所以你去smartlist.com斜杠live参加11月15日的好莱坞露天剧场演出。伙计们，这将是，这对我们来说会非常伤脑筋。因为我们在好莱坞露天剧场上面做什么？我们几乎做不到这个。我们几乎做不到这个。我会告诉你，我的嘉宾是电影界最大的明星之一。
So it was my guest. Really? Yes, my guest also is one of the biggest stars out there. Let's have a little side bet. You and me. I can't wait. I'm going to have a single up on a camera. We're going to single up on you.
我的嘉宾也是。真的吗？是的，我的嘉宾也是那里最大的明星之一。让我们打个小赌。你和我。我等不及了。我要在摄像机上拍一个单人镜头。我们要拍你的单人镜头。
J.B, when my guest comes out gets announced. Oh, and you'll know why. Oh, yeah, it's going to be great. It's going to be great. It's going to be a guest that's going to make me nervous? It's going to be so great on so many levels. I can't wait. All right, Shawnee, you can be the judge between Will and I's guest.
J.B，当我的嘉宾出来被宣布时。哦，你会知道为什么。哦，是的，这会很棒。这会很棒。这将是一个让我紧张的嘉宾吗？它会在很多层面上都很棒。我等不及了。好吧，肖尼，你可以做威尔和我嘉宾之间的裁判。
Will, let's you and I have a little side $10 bet of who is the bigger guest. And, Shawnee, you get to decide. All right. We'll just do it, let go. We'll do 10, 10, 10, 20. That's a big reveal. I'll do it 10, 10, 10, 20, and presses. Automatic presses.
威尔，让我们打个10美元的小赌，看谁的嘉宾更大。而且，肖尼，你来决定。好吧。我们做吧，开始吧。我们打10、10、10、20。那是一个大揭秘。我打10、10、10、20，还有自动加注。
Okay. All right. I tell you what we are. We're pressed for time because we want to get into our guest who is. Get this, award-winning, actor, writer, director, New York Times best-selling author, a podcaster, singer-songwriter, multiple albums, multiple Golden Globes,
好的。好吧。我告诉你我们是什么。我们时间紧迫，因为我们想进入我们的嘉宾，他是。听好了，获奖演员、编剧、导演、《纽约时报》畅销书作家、播客、创作歌手、多张专辑、多个金球奖、
multiple Emmy nominations, SAG Awards. He's known for his, an iconic TV show, which was his sort of breakthrough, even though he'd been doing it for a long time. He's got a degree from Princeton. He's got a master's from Yale in literature. I'm sure he still has an unfinished PhD that I want to ask him about. He's one of the all-time great things.
多个艾美奖提名、演员工会奖。他以他的标志性电视节目而闻名，这是他的某种突破，尽管他已经做了很长时间了。他有普林斯顿的学位。他有耶鲁大学的文学硕士学位。我相信他还有一个未完成的博士学位，我想问问他。他是史上最伟大的人之一。
You guys, it's David Dukovny. Oh, David DeCovny. Yes, yes. Hey, David. Was that not who you were going to guess, Shoney? No, I thought it was David de C.C. Oh. Wow.
伙计们，是大卫·杜楚尼。哦，大卫·杜楚尼。是的，是的。嘿，大卫。那不是你要猜的人吗，肖尼？不，我以为是戴维·德·C.C。哦。哇。
Often, often, often mistaken for one another. I don't think Louis has a master's in literature, all due respect from you. Yeah, but you said Princeton. You said Princeton as well. And Princeton first. Is that true? David, welcome. Christ, David.
经常，经常，经常被误认为是对方。我不认为路易斯有文学硕士学位，恕我直言。是的，但你说了普林斯顿。你也说了普林斯顿。而且先是普林斯顿。那是真的吗？大卫，欢迎。天哪，大卫。
Is it true? Yes, it's true. Thank you. God. This is so wonderful. David, why would you, you're such a, you know, I remember the, we spoke about a year ago where you had dinner. Let me just say, I don't like the tone of that.
是真的吗？是的，是真的。谢谢。上帝。这真是太美妙了。大卫，你为什么会，你真是个，你知道，我记得大约一年前我们谈过，当时你们吃了晚餐。让我先说，我不喜欢那种语气。
Why? Immediately. Why? Why? Why would they give you a degree? No, no, no, no. It wasn't that. It wasn't that.
为什么？立刻。为什么？为什么？为什么他们会给你一个学位？不，不，不，不。不是那样的。不是那样的。
Why? It wasn't that. Go ahead. Why would I what? The why would you, because you graduated, you were, you were head of your class in high school, and then you go to Princeton, and then you go to Princeton, you go to you go to, Yale. And then I feel like you lowered yourself to come into show
为什么？不是那样的。继续。为什么我会什么？那个为什么你会，因为你毕业了，你是，你是高中班里的第一名，然后你去普林斯顿，然后你去普林斯顿，你去你去，耶鲁。然后我觉得你降低了身份进入演艺圈
business a little bit. You know, a little bit. Why would you do that, David? Well, clearly I have a gaping hole. A gaping hole inside me. But yeah, he decided to slum it. You slummed it with us, morons. Yeah, what is that?
圈子一点点。你知道，一点点。你为什么要那样做，大卫？好吧，显然我有一个巨大的空洞。我内心有一个巨大的空洞。但是的，他决定屈尊降贵。你和我们这些白痴一起屈尊降贵。是的，那是什么？
What did you? Go ahead. No, that's it. No, I want to, I just want you to walk me through your academic prowess. I'm fascinated with all this stuff. Well, at Princeton, I majored in English literature and I wrote my thesis on Samuel Beckett's novels. Come on.
你做了什么？继续。不，就是这样。不，我想，我只是想让你带我了解一下你的学术造诣。我对所有这些东西都很着迷。好吧，在普林斯顿，我主修英语文学，我的论文写的是塞缪尔·贝克特的小说。来吧。
Wow. Because, well, let me tell you why I wrote on the novels because nobody writes on the novels and I didn't have to do that much work in research because I could just make the shit up myself. All right. This is nothing to compare it to. No chat GPT cheating.
哇。因为，好吧，让我告诉你我为什么写小说，因为没有人写小说，而且我不需要做太多的研究工作，因为我可以自己编造这些废话。好吧。这没什么可比的。没有ChatGPT作弊。
It was an open field. And then what happened that was Princeton or that was Yale? That was Princeton. And then I took a year off and I traveled and I didn't really know what I wanted to do at all.
那是一个开放的领域。然后发生了什么，那是普林斯顿还是耶鲁？那是普林斯顿。然后我休了一年假，我旅行了，我真的根本不知道我想做什么。
I just knew I wanted to be a writer. And then I applied for a Mellon Fellowship which I got from the Mellon Foundation which they were trying to lure people that might go into money-making businesses and steer them towards academia. So it was for people to get PhDs
我只知道我想成为一名作家。然后我申请了梅隆奖学金，我从梅隆基金会得到了它，他们试图引诱那些可能进入赚钱行业的人，并将他们引向学术界。所以这是为了让人们获得博士学位
who might not be able to afford staying in school. So I got one of those and I went to Yale and I thought that I'd become a professor of English literature and then write novels in my summertime. That's the plan. And forgive me, have you written like a hundred novels
那些可能负担不起留在学校的人。所以我得到了一个，我去了耶鲁，我想我会成为一名英语文学教授，然后在夏天写小说。这就是计划。原谅我，你写了一百本小说吗
and I'm an idiot? I've written four or five novels. Wow. Yeah, and I just had a book of poems come out. Oh, that's cool. David, this is... And then, by the way, he's also... He's omitting the fact that he's put out a number of records.
而我是个白痴？我写了四五本小说。哇。是的，我刚出了一本诗集。哦，那很酷。大卫，这是……而且，顺便说一句，他也是……他忽略了这样一个事实，即他发行了许多唱片。
He just finished a tour. Am I right? You just finished a tour in Europe. Yeah, yeah. Oh, no, this was in the States, this one, but go ahead. But last year you were on tour in Europe. Yeah. And I listened to your records.
你刚结束巡演。我说得对吗？你刚在欧洲结束了巡演。是的，是的。哦，不，这次是在美国，但继续。但去年你在欧洲巡演。是的。我听了你的唱片。
By the way, your music is great. Oh, thank you. Sometimes, and I mean this, I'll do you say, sometimes when you see people who do multiple disciplines, they're like, I'm going to put a record out. You listen to you're out? Yeah, it's pretty good. Your records are really good.
顺便说一句，你的音乐很棒。哦，谢谢。有时，我是认真的，我会说，有时当你看到从事多种学科的人时，他们会说，我要发行一张唱片。你听你的出来了吗？是的，相当不错。你的唱片真的很好。
I mean, they're very, these aren't just hobby records. And I'm a music lover. Really, really good stuff. I mean. I love that tune, Hell or High Water. I think that's a great tune. Yeah, it's super good. What type of, is it rock and roll?
我是说，它们非常，这些不仅仅是业余爱好唱片。而且我是一个音乐爱好者。真的，真的很好的东西。我是说。我喜欢那首曲子，《地狱或高水》。我认为那是一首很棒的曲子。是的，超级好。是什么类型的，是摇滚乐吗？
Yeah, I guess it's... I'd say it's rock and roll. Yeah, like 70s rock, you know, late 60s rock. Like yacht rock? Not quite like yacht rock. I'm not very jazzy. I stay off the water. I try to stay off the water.
是的，我想是……我会说是摇滚乐。是的，像70年代的摇滚，你知道，60年代末的摇滚。像游艇摇滚？不太像游艇摇滚。我不太爵士乐。我远离水。我尽量远离水。
No, it's kind of like indie rock in a way. I mean, sorry to forgive me for saying that, but I'm a 90s indie rock dinosaur myself. Well, the 90s was kind of like the garage vacation. of 70s rock in my mind. Oh, interesting. And so I think 70s and 90s have a lot in common.
不，它在某种程度上有点像独立摇滚。我是说，抱歉原谅我这么说，但我自己是一个90年代的独立摇滚恐龙。好吧，90年代在我的脑海里有点像70年代摇滚的车库度假。哦，有趣。所以我认为70年代和90年代有很多共同点。
And you're playing the guitar there and you're singing as well? I don't play the guitar on stage because I'm kind of self-taught on the guitar, so I have an inability to play it the same way twice, which is not very nice for my band. So I write the songs. And do you sing them? And I sing in my fashion.
而且你在那里弹吉他，你也唱歌？我不上台弹吉他，因为我在吉他上算是自学的，所以我有一种无法两次以同样方式弹奏它的能力，这对我的乐队来说不太好。所以我写歌。你唱它们吗？我以我的方式唱歌。
So on stage, you have no guitar. as a crutch for... I think that's going to say... I think that's where you're going. You just kind of work the mic and the core. You know, you hold on to that fucking mic stand for dear life, that's what happens. I wouldn't know what to do. It's like a life jacket.
所以在舞台上，你没有吉他作为拐杖……我想那是你要说的……我想那是你要去的地方。你只是有点操作麦克风和核心。你知道，你为了亲爱的生命抓住那个他妈的麦克风架，这就是发生的事情。我不知道该怎么办。这就像一件救生衣。
You're like Liam Gallagher does that, you know, with the... Oh, yeah, it's amazing because, you know, when I first started performing live, I just thought, well, I'm like the emcee. And I want people to have a good time, you know. And I'm dancing around and making a fool of myself. And then it was actually my wife said to me, you know, you don't have to move around someone. Oh, no.
你就像利亚姆·加拉格尔那样做，你知道，用……哦，是的，这太神奇了，因为，你知道，当我第一次开始现场表演时，我只是想，好吧，我是主持人。我想让人们玩得开心，你知道。我在跳舞，让自己出丑。然后实际上是我妻子对我说，你知道，你不必到处走动。哦，不。
And then I saw, you know, then I saw Liam. And Liam is just still. You know, he's just still. He's got his hands behind his back for the most part. Yeah, kind of leaning up in a way. And it's really powerful to be still. Yeah. Do you close your eyes a lot?
然后我看到了，你知道，然后我看到了利亚姆。利亚姆只是静止不动。你知道，他只是静止不动。他大部分时间把手放在背后。是的，有点倾斜。静止不动是非常强大的。是的。你经常闭上眼睛吗？
Sometimes. Sometimes I close my eyes. And then I go, this isn't good. There could be shit happening out there that I need to keep an eye on. Do you ever go full Sia and just turn your back to the audience? But David, David, I just want to say, so you were, David, you were self-taught on guitar. I think you only started playing guitar a couple years before your first album. Is that true?
有时。有时我闭上眼睛。然后我说，这不好。外面可能有我需要留意的事情。你有没有完全像Sia那样背对着观众？但大卫，大卫，我只是想说，所以你是，大卫，你是自学吉他的。我想你只在第一张专辑前几年才开始弹吉他。那是真的吗？
True, yeah. So you barely start, you basically teach yourself how to play guitar for a couple years. Then you have the audacity to be like, all right, well, I'm going to write a record. And how are you, do you know how to read and write music? How did you do that? How was that process? No, I don't know how to read and write music. But here's something that you guys might appreciate as actors. When I decided I wanted to learn guitar, I'm not 100% self-taught.
真的，是的。所以你几乎开始，你基本上自学了几年吉他。然后你有胆量说，好吧，好吧，我要写一张唱片。你是怎么，你知道怎么读写音乐吗？你是怎么做到的？那个过程是怎样的？不，我不知道怎么读写音乐。但这里有一些你们作为演员可能会欣赏的东西。当我决定我想学吉他时，我不是100%自学的。
When I decided I wanted to learn, I was doing Californication at the time. And I said to Tom Capone was the producer, I think Hank Moody should learn how to play guitar. So I could get the free lessons. That's amazing. The intelligence permeates everything you do. I know, I know. He's playing four-dimensional chess, if that's a thing. So I, also with singing, I'm not like Sean.
当我决定我想学时，我当时正在做《加州靡情》。我对制片人汤姆·卡彭说，汉克·穆迪应该学会弹吉他。所以我可以得到免费的课程。这太神奇了。智慧渗透到你所做的一切中。我知道，我知道。他在下四维象棋，如果那是一回事的话。所以我也唱歌，我不像肖恩。
I can't, I'm not that kind of a singer. I'm not either. Yes, you are. And it's been a journey to try and put over the song. Because I can hear melodies that I can't necessarily sing, which is weird. I never thought that was a possibility. Well, you know, I'm just really quick. Sometimes the best singers are the, quote, untrained singing,
我不能，我不是那种歌手。我也不是。是的，你是。尝试传达这首歌是一段旅程。因为我可以听到我未必能唱出来的旋律，这很奇怪。我从来没想过那是一种可能性。好吧，你知道，我真的很快。有时最好的歌手是，引用，未经训练的歌唱，
because you don't think about it. You're not in your head about it. You know, David, we had Michael Stipe, our friend from R.m. on here a while ago, and he was talking about that. Wonderful singer. He was so good. And that first record that he made
因为你不去想它。你没有在脑子里想它。你知道，大卫，我们前段时间请来了我们的朋友，来自R.E.M.的迈克尔·斯泰普，他在谈论那个。很棒的歌手。他太棒了。而他制作的第一张唱片
when he was down in Athens, Georgia with those guys, Radio Free Europe, I think, was their first single. And he was talking about, he basically was singing gibberish, and he didn't know how to sing. Do you remember that guy's? He was talking, he was like, I just kind of winged it. Yeah. Because he didn't know what he...
当他在佐治亚州雅典市和那些家伙在一起时，《Radio Free Europe》，我想，是他们的第一首单曲。他在谈论，他基本上是在唱胡言乱语，他不知道怎么唱歌。你还记得那些家伙吗？他在谈论，他就像，我只是有点即兴发挥。是的。因为他不知道他……
And he kind of taught himself how to... And he got better as he won. I think the correct term is wung. He wung it. He won't. Sorry. Sorry, Jason. I don't mean to embarrass you.
他有点自学了怎么……而且他随着赢而变得更好。我认为正确的术语是“wung”。他即兴发挥了。他不会。抱歉。抱歉，杰森。我不是要让你尴尬。
I'm so sorry. Stickler. He got an answer to English from a school bus. So, hey, hey, Sean. Hey. Yeah. Okay? Really, speaking of music, struck a chord with...
我很抱歉。死板。他从校车上得到了一个英语答案。所以，嘿，嘿，肖恩。嘿。是的。好吗？真的，说到音乐，触动了……
Now, David, this is... I don't... I don't read. And I'm not proud to say that. you strike me as a reader though i'm surprised i appreciate he reads scripts he doesn't read a lot of this it's the glasses um it's just the glasses but it to be an english major and to and to say you want to be a writer and you are a writer and to be a perfect it just it sounds like a lot of reading a lot of sitting down can't get anything by you nothing else going on
现在，大卫，这是……我不……我不读。而且我并不以此为荣。你给我的印象是一个读者，虽然我很惊讶，我欣赏他读剧本，他不读很多这个，这是眼镜，嗯，这只是眼镜，但作为一名英语专业学生，并且说你想成为一名作家，而你是一名作家，并且是一个完美主义者，这听起来像是大量的阅读，大量的坐下来，什么都瞒不过你，没有其他事情发生
there's total silence in the house maybe there's a little bit of classical music or something nothing with lyrics because that'll distract you but like and Will I wanted to ask you about this too at times and then I just said fuck it I don't want to talk to Will how do you do that how do you just say of all the things I could
房子里一片寂静，也许有一点古典音乐之类的，没有歌词，因为那会让你分心，但像，威尔，我也想问你这个，有时然后我就说去他妈的，我不想和威尔说话，你是怎么做到的，你是怎么只是说，在所有我可以
be doing I would rather just sit in this chair and shut out the world and stare at this stack of paper and go left to right top to bottom word after word after word after word So I'm not reading Hebrew at all is what you're saying.
做的事情中，我宁愿只是坐在椅子上，把世界关在外面，盯着这堆纸，从左到右，从上到下，一个词一个词地写下去。所以我根本不是在读希伯来语，这就是你要说的。
I mean I just I wish my parents for all the good that they did I wish they had somehow tricked me into really loving that process because there's so much that I'm missing. Are you talking about writing or reading? Reading.
我是说，我只是，我希望我的父母为了他们所做的一切好事，我希望他们以某种方式诱骗我真正热爱那个过程，因为我错过了很多东西。你在谈论写作还是阅读？阅读。
Writing I've got but it's the reading that's I don't know. Have you ever loved reading a novel or reading? I have had a back into a couple of those but it was, you know, it wasn't by choice. I do not read for pleasure.
写作我有，但阅读是，我不知道。你有没有喜欢过读小说或阅读？我有过几次，但那是，你知道，不是出于选择。我不为了快乐而阅读。
All the jokes, J.B., that I make about you not reading, I will say, of the handful that I mentioned that you have read, you've always said you really enjoyed reading them. So that's what's surprising to me. I'm like, well, why don't you double... It is the time allotment. It is the decision to go sit in a chair in a quiet corner of a house and shut everything out and do that.
所有的笑话，J.B.，我关于你不阅读的笑话，我会说，在我提到的你读过的少数几本中，你总是说你真的很喜欢读它们。所以这让我感到惊讶。我当时想，好吧，为什么你不加倍……这是时间分配。这是决定去房子的安静角落坐在椅子上，关掉一切并做这件事。
There's so much discipline that I have for other things, but I just don't have it for reading. I'm so envious of that. Yeah. I think it's just, it really just comes from my parents, I think. On my mother's side, she was a, from a small town in Scotland, and the only way to advance for her family, which were generations of, I did that 20,
我有太多的纪律用于其他事情，但我就是没有阅读的纪律。我对此非常羡慕。是的。我想这真的只是来自我的父母，我想。在我母亲那边，她来自苏格兰的一个小镇，对她的家庭来说，这是几代人的，我做了那个20，
I did that Root, Finding a Root show. So I found out that I come from a long line of fishmongers. Oh, yeah. Wow, that's wild. So the only way out of the fishmongering business In fact, one of my ancestors' occupation was widow of fishmonger. I didn't even know that was a job. I was like, how does that pay?
我做了那个《寻根》节目。所以我发现我来自一个长长的鱼贩家族。哦，是的。哇，那太疯狂了。所以离开鱼贩生意的唯一方法，事实上，我的一位祖先的职业是鱼贩的遗孀。我甚至不知道那是一份工作。我当时想，那工资怎么算？
How does that pay? Not well, is my guess. Well, you need the person to die, first of us. You need to be included in the will. And so the only way out of that place in society was education for my mother. my mother was the first woman, first person in her family and a woman in the 1940s to go to college. And so she was very much just somebody
那工资怎么算？我的猜测是不好。好吧，你需要那个人先死。你需要被列入遗嘱。所以离开那个社会地位的唯一方法就是我母亲的教育。我母亲是第一个女人，她家族中的第一个人，也是20世纪40年代的一个女人去上大学。所以她非常只是一个
who believed in the power of education and of reading and writing as a social climbing tool. Is also the appeal of reading sometime like the pure escapism of, because I do remember this one book, I really enjoyed reading once. I was once on a job that I didn't enjoy. I didn't like where I was.
相信教育的力量，以及阅读和写作作为一种社会攀升工具的人。阅读有时也是一种吸引力，就像纯粹的逃避主义，因为我确实记得这一本书，我曾经非常喜欢读。我曾经在一份我不喜欢的工作上。我不喜欢我在哪里。
I was on location somewhere, and I was lonely. And it was great to just like, I was dying to get back into the book, any chance I could because it would travel me from where I was. That feeling is amazing. Yeah. Well, it used to be, you know, I think the place of books has been taken by, you know, TV and movies,
我在某个地方出差，我很孤独。能回到书里真是太好了，任何机会我都可以，因为它会把我从我所在的地方带走。那种感觉太棒了。是的。好吧，过去是，你知道，我认为书的位置已经被，你知道，电视和电影取代了，
you know, that escape. But before there was that technology, you know, this is what you had. You had the book, And people used to read books on set, I think way back in the day you did. But, J.B., I would say that you, as somebody who travels a lot, you're on a lot of, you're on planes a lot. Yeah. That's such a great time to get that escape where you're not watching. Can I send you one of my books?
你知道，那种逃避。但在那种技术出现之前，你知道，这就是你所拥有的。你有了书，而且人们过去在片场看书，我想很久以前你确实看过。但是，J.B.，我会说你，作为一个经常旅行的人，你经常在飞机上。是的。那是一个获得那种逃避的绝佳时间，你没有在看。我可以寄给你我的一本书吗？
Yes, please. Yes. I'll send you one of my books for a plane ride. It's baseball contingent. Is it? It's near baseball. It's called Bucky Fucking Dent. I made a movie of it.
是的，请。是的。我会寄给你我的一本书，供你在飞机上阅读。它是棒球相关的。是吗？它接近棒球。它叫《巴基·福金·登特》。我把它拍成了电影。
I made a movie of it. But I want you to read the book. I'll send you the book. Now, well, that sounds like nonfiction. No, no, it's fiction. Is it? It just uses that moment in time. Okay.
我把它拍成了电影。但我想要你读这本书。我会寄给你这本书。现在，好吧，那听起来像非虚构作品。不，不，它是虚构的。是吗？它只是利用了那个时刻。好的。
And then does that make you a big Yankee fan? I am a big Yankee fan, and I heard what you said earlier. You got a big day today. Big day today. So David, so David, all of this to say. So then my father, my father's family, his father wrote for the foreword, which was the only Yiddish daily newspaper. in America, the longest running one.
那这会让你成为一个大的洋基队球迷吗？我是一个大的洋基队球迷，我听到了你刚才说的话。你今天有个大日子。今天是个大日子。所以大卫，所以大卫，所有这些都是为了说。所以然后我的父亲，我父亲的家庭，他的父亲为《前进报》写作，这是唯一的意第绪语日报。
And he wrote kind of, in a Dickensian way, he wrote cliffhangers for the paper. He wrote stories about Little Nell or whatever, somebody being tied to the train tracks, that kind of a thing. And my father, his entire life, my father had to work kind of a 9-to-5 job, but he always said he was a novelist. He always said he was a novelist.
在美国，运行时间最长的。他以一种狄更斯的方式写作，他为报纸写悬念故事。他写关于小内尔的故事，或者什么，有人被绑在火车轨道上，那种事情。而我的父亲，他的一生，我的父亲不得不做一份朝九晚五的工作，但他总是说他是一名小说家。他总是说他是一名小说家。
And at the age of 73, two years before he died, he published his first novel. So he was a hot young novelist. at the age of 73. So I'm coming out of that kind of history of respect for the word, respect for the efficacy of the word, respect for education.
而在73岁时，在他去世前两年，他出版了他的第一部小说。所以他是一个热门的年轻小说家。在73岁时。所以我来自那种对文字的尊重、对文字功效的尊重、对教育的尊重的历史。
Just it was all, it was all, that was part of my growing up, that was part of my foundation. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. That's funny, David. My dad also, who worked forever, but he's been retired for a while,
只是它全部，它全部，那是我成长的一部分，那是我基础的一部分。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。那很有趣，大卫。我的父亲也，他工作了很久，但他退休了一段时间，
but since COVID has written two novels. Amazing. And he wrote his last one and came out when he was 86. He's just written it last year, yeah. What is the name of it, and where can purchasers find it? Yeah, well, his latest is the Monmouth Manifesto, which is an interesting novel, and it's sort of historical fiction, if you will.
但自从新冠疫情以来，他写了两部小说。太棒了。他写了他的最后一部，并在他86岁时出版。他去年刚写完，是的。它的名字是什么，买家在哪里可以找到它？是的，好吧，他最新的作品是《蒙茅斯宣言》，这是一部有趣的小说，它算是历史小说，如果你愿意的话。
I love that. This is about when Caterpillar's change into... No, it's about, it's sort of pre-eastern, It's about the American Revolution in a way, Monmouth County, New Jersey is the reference about loyalists going to Canada based on one of my ancestors and about really at the heart of the revolution.
我喜欢那个。这是关于毛毛虫变成……不，它是关于，它算是前东方的，它在某种程度上是关于美国革命，蒙茅斯县，新泽西州是关于保皇党去加拿大的参考，基于我的一位祖先，并且真正处于革命的核心。
I was just trying to do a moth joke. Okay, sorry, you don't want to get into it. Not really. This is why you're Canadian. Let the readers buy it and discover it. What's his name? My dad's name is James Arnett. You sure?
我只是想讲一个飞蛾笑话。好的，抱歉，你不想深入讨论它。不太想。这就是为什么你是加拿大人。让读者买它并发现它。他叫什么名字？我父亲的名字是詹姆斯·阿内特。你确定？
Yeah. Emerson James Arnett, if you will. Oh, my dad. My dad wrote. uh me off so oh no shan oh god it would be it would be funny if it wasn't so true he wrote me off no no he wrote a goodbye note his way wrote see ya that's where bye came from by the way came from sean's dad bye wait wait david david david so you so i do want to so so you get in you you graduate you go to
是的。爱默生·詹姆斯·阿内特，如果你愿意的话。哦，我的父亲。我的父亲写了。呃，我，所以哦不，肖恩，哦天哪，如果它不是那么真实，它会很有趣，他把我写掉了，不不，他写了一张告别纸条，他的方式写了再见，顺便说一句，再见来自肖恩的父亲，再见，等等，等等，大卫，大卫，大卫，所以你，所以我确实想，所以你进入，你毕业，你去
I kind of want to stick with Sean. I know, I do. We've done a lot. Anytime you have a question on Sean, please. Interrupt me. But you decide, and you're studying English-lit and you get a master's. And then what's the moment you go, like,
我有点想坚持肖恩。我知道，我确实想。我们做了很多。任何时候你有关于肖恩的问题，请。打断我。但你决定，你正在学习英语文学，你获得了硕士学位。然后你什么时候，像，
all right, I'm going to put this down for a second. I'm going to dip my toe. What was your first acting job, and why did it come about? I was at Yale. I was getting my Ph.D. or so, I thought. And Yale is famous for its drama school. and they have a lot of productions going on all the time. So I decided I was going to start trying to take classes over at the drama department,
好吧，我要把这个放下一下。我要蘸一下我的脚趾。你的第一份表演工作是什么，它为什么会出现？我在耶鲁。我正在攻读博士学位，或者说，我想。耶鲁以其戏剧学院而闻名。他们一直有很多作品在进行。所以我决定我要开始尝试在戏剧系上课，
and they were very loose about it. They would just let me walk in and do writing classes, because I thought maybe I'm going to write plays because the idea of writing novels or poems seems so very lonely to me. And I was 22, 23 years old, and I was just sitting in a room all day long alone trying to write. It's like, this is fucked up, you know, this is not. you know i like people not as romantic as you thought no but i liked i like collaborating i like so i thought okay i'll write plays in that way at least i'll i'll get out into the world and so i met
他们对此非常宽松。他们只是让我走进去上写作课，因为我想也许我要写剧本，因为写小说或诗歌的想法对我来说似乎太孤独了。我当时22、23岁，我只是整天独自坐在房间里试图写作。就像，这太他妈的了，你知道，这不是。你知道我喜欢人，不像你想象的那么浪漫，不，但我喜欢，我喜欢合作，我喜欢，所以我认为好吧，我会写剧本，那样至少我会走到世界上，所以我遇到了
these all these actors and they're always looking for bodies because there's so many productions going on around and you know and they said hey you know come and do this this thing there's arthur schnitzler play we're doing um which name escapes me but you can play the count de la tremway or something. I had one or two lines. And I liked it. It wasn't like, oh, this is a revelation. In fact, I thought, oh, well, I'm comfortable, and I was so comfortable in between the first and the second performances, I smoked a joint. Have the second one go. Yeah. Yeah. Not so good. That's really funny. I was so cocky. I was like, I got this.
这些所有的演员，他们总是在寻找身体，因为周围有太多的作品在进行，你知道，他们说嘿，你知道，来做这个，这个东西，有一个亚瑟·施尼茨勒的剧本我们正在做，嗯，名字我忘了，但你可以扮演德拉特姆韦伯爵之类的。我有一两句台词。我喜欢它。这不像，哦，这是一个启示。事实上，我想，哦，好吧，我很舒服，我在第一场和第二场表演之间非常舒服，我抽了一根大麻。让第二场去吧。是的。是的。不太好。这真的很有趣。我太自大了。我当时想，我得到了这个。
And then I was like, oh, I don't have anything. I got people looking at me. Did you then sign up for acting classes? I started taking classes in New York with a woman named Marcia Hauffrecht who taught Strasbourg Method. She was associated with the actor's studio. And that was wonderful because she was completely supportive.
然后我当时想，哦，我什么都没有。我有人看着我。你后来报名参加表演课了吗？我开始在纽约和一位名叫玛西娅·豪弗雷希特的女士一起上课，她教斯特拉斯堡方法。她与演员工作室有关。那太棒了，因为她完全支持。
It was all about the interior world. All the things that are so difficult to work on when you're actually a working actor. But were you thinking about it in terms of like informing your playwriting? Was that part of it? Yes, that's what I was telling myself. So it wasn't like this is going to be my
这完全是关于内心世界。所有那些当你真正成为一名职业演员时很难处理的事情。但你在考虑它，比如告知你的剧本写作吗？那是其中的一部分吗？是的，那就是我告诉自己的。所以它不像这是我的
This is going to be my future occupation. No, I thought if I'm going to write plays, I should probably know what it's like to say these, whatever lines I'm going to write, see if they're sayable up on stage. Yeah. And so that was my approach. And then at some point I was just like,
这将是我未来的职业。不，我想如果我要写剧本，我可能应该知道说这些，无论我要写什么台词，看看它们在舞台上是否说得出来。是的。所以那是我的方法。然后有那么一刻我只是想，
I liked, I'd played sports my whole life, and I liked the team aspect of acting and of making things. I liked the high wire kind of put up or shut up feeling. Did it ever frustrate you that it didn't hold the same sort of academic rigor that because it is not with all respect to our
我喜欢，我一生都在做运动，我喜欢表演和制作东西的团队方面。我喜欢那种高空钢丝般的“要么做要么闭嘴”的感觉。它有没有让你感到沮丧，因为它没有保持同样的学术严谨性，因为它是，恕我直言，对我们的
colleagues that are actors it is not the it doesn't have this sort of highbrow sophisticated reputation that that a playwright It's just a different game
同事是演员，它不是，它没有这种高雅、复杂的声誉，剧作家……这只是一个不同的游戏。
it's just a different game it's like baseball and basketball whatever it's just I look at life as a series of games or setups and this was just another game and I knew it had different rules and I know that I would have to examine different strengths in order to...
这只是一个不同的游戏，就像棒球和篮球一样，无论什么，它只是我把生活看作一系列游戏或设置，而这只是另一个游戏，我知道它有不同的规则，我知道我必须检查不同的优势才能……
Yeah, and probably less constraints, too, than writing. Because it is such a different discipline. It probably started exercising a different muscle creatively that you're like, oh, this feels good. Yes, it was the emotional aspect of my life, which had been neglected because I was, you know, I was in academia, which doesn't really prize, you know, being volatile. Right.
是的，而且可能比写作有更少的限制。因为它是一个如此不同的学科。它可能开始锻炼了一个不同的肌肉，创造性地让你觉得，哦，这感觉很好。是的，这是我生活中情感的一面，它一直被忽视，因为我，你知道，我在学术界，它并不真正珍视，你知道，变得反复无常。对。
So the emotional side of it and the teamwork side of it is being satisfied, but do you feel like this fucking academic superhero that you have inside of you has been satisfied, has been utilized properly in your life thus far?
所以它的情感方面和团队合作方面得到了满足，但你觉得你内心拥有的这个他妈的学术超级英雄是否得到了满足，是否在你的生活中得到了适当的利用？
Yes, now, now that I, when I started writing novels, about 10 years ago now. And, you know, people, I go on good reads and I'll read, I'll read, you know, people's suggestions. Yeah. Oh, you will.
是的，现在，现在我，当我开始写小说时，大约10年前。而且，你知道，人们，我上Goodreads，我会读，我会读，你知道，人们的建议。是的。哦，你会的。
You will? stupidly yeah I will I will be accused of showing off my learning when in fact I don't write with any books around it's all in my head
你会吗？愚蠢地，是的，我会，我会因为炫耀我的学识而被指责，事实上我写的时候周围没有任何书，它全在我的脑子里。
if I'm quoting something or if I'm referencing another a great work of literature it's coming from my head it's coming from my memory so I'm not doing it just to show up but it's part of me and I really feel like
如果我引用什么东西，或者如果我参考另一部伟大的文学作品，它来自我的脑子，它来自我的记忆，所以我这样做不仅仅是为了炫耀，但它是我的一个部分，我真的觉得
I finally joined in the conversation with these people that I grew up reading and loving and feeling like this is the conversation I want to be involved with and I'm sure you guys have had this as actors where you're like okay now I'm in conversation with the with the people that I want to be in conversation with that's true that's true and then what about did you ever sorry shiny did you did you ever end up writing any plays or any screen plays have you kind of married the two yeah yeah yeah in fact the novel writing came out of not being able to make a screenplay.
我终于加入了与我从小阅读、热爱并觉得这是我想参与的对话的这些人的对话，我相信你们作为演员也有过这种经历，你们会说好吧，现在我正在与我想与之对话的人进行对话，那是真的，那是真的，然后关于你有没有，抱歉肖尼，你有没有最终写过任何剧本或任何电影剧本，你是否有点结合了两者，是的，是的，事实上，小说写作来自于无法制作电影剧本。
Bucky Fucking Dent, I wrote as a screenplay probably in 2005 or six. And then I couldn't get a made. Usually my soul goes towards, like, we're independent kind of stories. And so, Bucky, I couldn't make. I got close, I got close, I got close, I couldn't make it. But then I finally did. And then I was like, I'm going to write it as a novel, and then I made it as a movie. So you flipped it.
《巴基·福金·登特》，我大概在2005年或06年写成了电影剧本。然后我无法制作它。通常我的灵魂倾向于，比如，我们是独立类型的故事。所以，巴基，我无法制作。我接近了，我接近了，我接近了，我无法制作它。但后来我终于做到了。然后我当时想，我要把它写成小说，然后我把它拍成了电影。所以你翻转了它。
You went the other way, so you read a screenplay. Because Will always talks about it. It's IP now. Because now your book is IP. So they love that, right? I don't know if they love that. Reverse engineering. I mean, no, Hollywood loves that.
你走了另一条路，所以你读了剧本。因为威尔总是在谈论它。现在它是IP了。因为现在你的书是IP了。所以他们喜欢那样，对吧？我不知道他们是否喜欢那样。逆向工程。我是说，不，好莱坞喜欢那样。
Was it a book first? Then we'll make it. I'll just say that as a director, you know, writing the novel of the screenplay was the best preparation I could have done as a director. Yeah, sure. Because I just knew. So, now I'm not suggesting that you have to do that next time
是先有书吗？然后我们再把它拍出来。我只想说，作为一名导演，你知道，写剧本的小说是我作为导演所能做的最好的准备。是的，当然。因为我就是知道了。所以，我现在并不是建议你下次必须这样做
to direct guys. No. No. Yeah. I'm just saying, for me, that worked. Is there a genre that you like writing more of than not? Oh, I mean, I'm just of the, I guess, you know, I go back to the movies when I started acting, you know, like James Brooks,
才能去执导。不。不。是的。我只是说，对我来说，那很有效。有没有什么类型是你比其他类型更喜欢写的？哦，我是说，我只是，我想，你知道，我回到了我刚开始演戏时的电影，你知道，比如詹姆斯·布鲁克斯，
just these movies that can live in a real, in terms of a deemant, you know, sobbing, but also laughing. Yeah, great. David O. Russell stuff. Yeah, yeah. Just like real emotional stuff. emotional but fucking funny yeah
就是那些能在现实中存在的电影，就那种，你知道，啜泣，但也大笑。是的，太棒了。大卫·O·拉塞尔的东西。是的，是的。就像真正的情感东西。情感丰富但该死的好笑，是的
flips back and forth yeah so that's that's always the balance that I'm looking for as an actor too it's always the balance I'm looking for that's just where I live
来回切换，是的，所以这总是我作为演员也在寻找的平衡，这总是我在寻找的平衡，这就是我生活的地方
so what ended up because so to go back to my what ended up becoming the first professional acting gig that you had that you went up for and you got
那么最后发生了什么，因为回到我的，最后成为了你参加并获得的第一个专业表演工作是什么
professional's a funny word well you know that you got a paycheck that you had to fill out a W4 or whatever you know well I'll tell you about two The first one I got paid for
“专业”是个有趣的词，嗯，你知道，就是你拿到了一张支票，你必须填写W4表格之类的，你知道，嗯，我会告诉你两个。第一个我拿到报酬的
And then there's the first one I did Which was even better But the first one I got paid for I believe was a Mickelow beer commercial Wow And I got on set And the guy told me
然后是我做的第一个，那甚至更好。但第一个我拿到报酬的，我相信是米凯洛啤酒广告。哇。我到了片场，那个人告诉我
Okay you're at the bar here The guy, the director Said you're at the bar here That's the guy Yeah that guy Some guy said you're at the bar And so okay this guy says I'm at the bar And you run into an old professor of yours
好的，你在这儿的酒吧。那个人，导演说，你在这儿的酒吧。那是那个人，是的，那个人。有个人说你在酒吧。所以好的，这个人说我在酒吧，然后你遇到了你的一位老教授
and you guys have a conversation and you're happy to see him and I was so fucking tight I was so nervous I'm 26 years old I mean I'm not young young and I had kind of staked my life on this path like I wasn't
你们聊了起来，你很高兴见到他，我当时紧张得要死。我26岁了，我是说我不算年轻，我已经把我的生活押在了这条路上，就像我没有
I wasn't going to get my PhD I wasn't going to be a professor and I just thought okay I'm going to do this thing and I'm going to be good at it now I get on set and I'm like I'm just tight because you feel like you need Did it do so much?
我不会去拿我的博士学位，我不会成为一名教授，我只是想，好吧，我要做这件事，我要把它做好。现在我到了片场，我感觉很紧绷，因为你觉得你需要做很多吗？
I just didn't know. I didn't know it was going to be so fucking tight. I know exactly what you mean, man. You needed that joint. It wasn't that way. It wasn't like, you know, oh, I'm in the right place. Yeah, right. It was like, no, I'm in the wrong place.
我只是不知道。我不知道会这么该死地紧张。我完全明白你的意思，伙计。你需要那根烟。不是那样的。不是那种，你知道，哦，我在正确的地方。是的，没错。而是，不，我在错误的地方。
Yeah. Cameras pointed at you. What? What? What? I can't do. I can't go on. I can't lie on the ground and go, ha.
是的。摄像机对着你。什么？什么？什么？我做不到。我不能继续。我不能躺在地上说，哈。
Huh. Right. So there's pretzels there, and I start, I toss one up, you know, catch it in my mouth. And the director's like, that's, I love that, I love that. Oh, no. And I just remember, again, that was my lifeline. And I was like, so I did it for like 10 minutes. And then I just remember the director going, okay with the pretzels.
哈。没错。所以那里有椒盐卷饼，我开始，我扔了一个，你知道，用嘴接住它。导演说，那，我喜欢那个，我喜欢那个。哦，不。我只记得，再一次，那是我的救命稻草。我就像，所以我做了大约10分钟。然后我只记得导演说，椒盐卷饼可以了。
We got the pretzels. I thought you were going to say you could never get it in your mouth again. No, that I could do. Yeah. So that was the first paying job was Mickelow. The first job that I remember was my acting class went and my acting class put on a night of one acts and I decided to adapt this Charles Bukowski short story
我们有椒盐卷饼了。我以为你会说你再也接不住了。不，那个我能做到。是的。所以那是第一份有报酬的工作是米凯洛。我记得的第一份工作是我参加的表演课，我的表演课举办了一个独幕剧之夜，我决定改编这个查尔斯·布考斯基的短篇小说
called The Copulating Mermaid of Venice, California. Sure. Sure. As one does. Sean's always referencing that. It's a painting, Sean has. I just call it mermaid. Yeah. Yeah.
叫《威尼斯，加利福尼亚的交配美人鱼》。当然。当然。正如人们所做的那样。肖恩总是提到那个。那是一幅画，肖恩有的。我只是叫它美人鱼。是的。是的。
So in this story, these two guys kind of, unemployed guys watch the hearse unload at the Venice morgue this is not a true kind of geographical thing but they can see it from the beach and they know the timing of it they know when the guys are going to come around they know when the body's going to be unattended and they're going to steal a body so they do they steal a body and they you know and here's where you know it's Bukowski and it's like the logic kind of fails you but they open it up and it's a beautiful woman and I decide I'm going to have sex with her and then I'm so ashamed of myself that I forced my buddy to have sex with her and then I'm sure you have this on your wall Sean I'm not
在这个故事里，这两个家伙，失业的家伙看着灵车在威尼斯停尸房卸货，这不是一个真实的地理情况，但他们能从海滩看到它，他们知道时间，他们知道那些人什么时候会来，他们知道尸体什么时候会无人看管，他们要偷一具尸体，所以他们做了，他们偷了一具尸体，然后你，你知道，这就是布考斯基，逻辑有点失效，但他们打开它，是一个美丽的女人，我决定我要和她发生性关系，然后我对自己感到非常羞耻，以至于我强迫我的伙伴和她发生性关系，然后我肯定你墙上有这个，肖恩，我没有
yeah no no it's it's how I should see the poster it's bizarre so then I I said we go what are we going to do the body I don't know I swim her out to the ocean to get rid of the body and then I come back and I say she wasn't dead she turned into a mermaid she was beautiful she swam away so it's this like beautiful not beautiful after this it's this gross horrible necrophilia and then coupled with this high romantic it's just Bukowski so we decide we're going to do it
是的，不，不，这是我应该看到的那个海报，太离奇了。所以然后我，我说我们该拿这具尸体怎么办？我不知道，我把她游到海里去处理掉尸体，然后我回来，我说她没死，她变成了一条美人鱼，她很美，她游走了，所以这就像美丽的，在这之后就不美了，这是一种恶心、可怕的恋尸癖，然后加上这种高度浪漫，这简直就是布考斯基，所以我们决定我们要演它
and I ask the class which of the women in the class is going to be the corpse and everybody's like yeah it'll be me it'll be me but then when the time comes to do it nobody shows to be the corpse and we're stuck and we had been the place where we were
我问班上哪位女性要当尸体，每个人都说，是的，我会是我，我会是我。但当真正要演的时候，没人愿意当尸体，我们被困住了，我们之前所在的地方
making these plays was a it was an S&M dudgeon sure Well, you know, of course. They're not used during the day. No, they're not used during the day. And we got to use it for two nights by cleaning up.
制作这些戏的地方是一个S&M地牢。当然。嗯，你知道，当然。它们白天不用。不，它们白天不用。我们得用它两个晚上，通过清理。
We had to clean up. That was a whole other different story. Yeah. But there was the madam there was named Magda. And she heard that we didn't have a body. So she said, why don't she use one of my blow-up dolls? Oh, my God. This is how things happen.
我们必须清理。那是另一个完全不同的故事。是的。但那里有个老鸨叫玛格达。她听说我们没有尸体。所以她说，为什么不用我的充气娃娃呢？哦，天哪。事情就是这样发生的。
They're at Yale. So, oh, she, yeah, right. And I'm thinking, maybe I should have stayed at you. So I had always put up like a bulwark on front of the stage to lay a body down so nobody could see the body. They couldn't see what was going on when I was supposedly making love to this body. And so I had this blow-up doll and I hadn't been able to rehearse with her. Sure. She wasn't available.
他们在耶鲁。所以，哦，她，是的，没错。我在想，也许我应该留在耶鲁。所以我总是会在舞台前放一个挡板来放尸体，这样就没人能看到尸体。当我在假装和这具尸体做爱时，他们看不到发生了什么。所以我有了这个充气娃娃，我没能和她排练。当然。她没空。
So as I was copulating with her, her arms and legs started flying out. Because she's only made of air, right? So the audience sees this. Like a used car lot, the things that you did are lots. I'm trying to do this most intense scene, young actor. Like I'm really like, oh, I'm fucking edgy. And the audience is laughing and laughing.
所以当我与她交配时，她的胳膊和腿开始飞出来。因为她只是由空气组成的，对吧？所以观众看到了这个。就像一个二手车行，你做的那些事情。我试图做这个最激烈的场景，年轻的演员。就像我真的，哦，我该死的前卫。而观众在笑啊笑。
And so in between performances, I went to Paragon. I hope you know it. It's a sporting good store. Sure, very well. And I got four ankle weights, and I weighed down her wrists and her ankles. So the next time, she didn't have as much mood out. But you still had the squeaky. The other part of it was when I walk through the audience and I go,
所以在演出间隙，我去了Paragon。我希望你知道它。那是一家体育用品店。当然，非常了解。我买了四个脚踝负重，我压住了她的手腕和脚踝。所以下一次，她没有那么多动作了。但你仍然有那个吱吱声。另一部分是当我走过观众席时，我说，
I put a pail of water off stage where I was going to go, because I swim around, and I come, you know, got to be wet. And so I walk through the audience. And I'm sure the audience is like, oh my God, this is the worst thing I've ever seen. And I'm thinking, yeah, that's right. I'm an edgy motherfucker. And I go around the corner to, and I realize it's totally quiet. There's no door. They can just hear me sponging myself down back there. They can just hear me. Oh, my God. So that was my first play. How long did it last? Those two nights
我在后台放了一桶水，我要去那里，因为我要游泳，然后我回来，你知道，必须是湿的。所以我走过观众席。我敢肯定观众在想，哦，天哪，这是我见过的最糟糕的事情。而我在想，是的，没错。我是一个前卫的混蛋。我绕过拐角，我意识到完全安静。没有门。他们只能听到我在后面用海绵擦洗自己。他们只能听到我。哦，天哪。所以那是我的第一部戏。持续了多久？那两个晚上
Okay, great Those two nights Two full nights Two full nights So you do So you do the Bukowski Where you're As you described
好的，太棒了。那两个晚上。两个完整的夜晚。两个完整的夜晚。所以你做，所以你做布考斯基，正如你描述的那样
Making Love to an inflatable doll In an S&M dungeon You do the Mickelow You threw away a PhD at Yale for this That's what I hear my mother saying Yeah, your parents At this point They're beaming with pride
与一个充气娃娃做爱，在一个S&M地牢里。你做了米凯洛。你为了这个放弃了耶鲁的博士学位。这就是我听到我母亲说的。是的，你的父母，在这一点上，他们正洋溢着自豪
And so then But then what's the sort of the first Because I'm leading up to X-Files So I want to get into X-Files a little bit We'd be remiss if we didn't get into X-Fellus because I was a fan of Xbox and I watched it. Yeah, same thing. So you get that, and that leads to what?
所以然后，但什么是那种第一个，因为我正在引向《X档案》，所以我想进入《X档案》一点。如果我们不进入《X档案》，我们会失职的，因为我是《X档案》的粉丝，我看了它。是的，同样。所以你得到了那个，那导致了什么？
Because what was the first film you did? An old girlfriend of mine whose name is Maggie Wheeler. That's her married name. She's a terrific actress. She was on... I'm going to give an address? Friends quite a lot. First and last, okay?
因为你拍的第一部电影是什么？我的一个老女朋友，她的名字叫玛吉·惠勒。那是她的夫姓。她是一位出色的女演员。她曾在……我要给出一个地址吗？《老友记》很多次。第一次也是最后一次，好吗？
She's on Friends. She was Janice on Friends. Oh, yeah. Chandler's... Yeah. Yes. Oh, yeah. Yeah. So Maggie was doing this film with Henry Jaglam, who just passed last week. And Henry's this Maverick independent filmmaker.
她在《老友记》里。她是《老友记》里的珍妮丝。哦，是的。钱德勒的……是的。是的。哦，是的。是的。所以玛吉正在和亨利·贾格拉姆拍这部电影，他上周刚去世。亨利是一位特立独行的独立电影制作人。
Yeah. And Maggie was going to be one of the three stars of this film called New Year's Day. And she asked Henry, you know, can you, David's acting now. Can you see if you can put them in? So Henry did. And I had a couple scenes in the movie, and they were good. They were kind of notable enough to kind of get me going. going here in LA and get an agent and you know at that point it was like it wasn't like
是的。玛吉将成为这部名为《新年》的电影的三位主演之一。她问亨利，你知道，大卫现在在演戏。你能看看能不能把他加进去吗？所以亨利做了。我在电影里有几个场景，它们很好。它们足够引人注目，让我在这里洛杉矶开始，找个经纪人，你知道，在那个时候，它不像
get your sag card was like how do I get film on myself you know yeah how do I show people that I'm not a vampire and I don't disappear when well people didn't have you didn't have phones and you couldn't put shit on YouTube the way kids can now and create their own stuff right so it was really this one it was one long scene in New Year's Day that really kind of opened it up for me in LA and then I you know I auditioned forever here and didn't get tons of stuff and would get you know so you move You moved to L.A. You moved to L.A. to do it, to go all in.
拿到你的演员工会卡，就像我怎么给自己拍电影，你知道，是的，我怎么向人们展示我不是吸血鬼，我不会消失，当，嗯，人们没有，你没有手机，你不能像现在的孩子那样把东西放到YouTube上，创造他们自己的东西，对吧？所以这真的是《新年》里的一个长镜头，真正为我在洛杉矶打开了局面，然后我，你知道，我在这里试镜了很久，没有得到很多东西，会得到，你知道，所以你搬家了，你搬到洛杉矶去做了，去全力以赴。
Exactly. What were you doing to pay the bills while you were swinging and missing? I was doing commercials. I would get commercials. So no waiting tables, no bartending, no typical. I bartended. I catered. Where did you live when you were here in L.A.?
完全正确。当你挥棒落空时，你在做什么来支付账单？我在拍广告。我会接到广告。所以没有端盘子，没有做酒保，没有典型的。我做过酒保。我做过餐饮。你住在洛杉矶的时候住在哪里？
I lived on 4th Street in Santa Monica. I got a sublet there. An efficiency apartment, which means it didn't have a kitchen, which means I did my dishes in the shower. when I had my shower. David. Yeah. Wow.
我住在圣莫尼卡的第四街。我在那里转租了一个地方。一个效率公寓，这意味着它没有厨房，这意味着我在淋浴时洗碗。当我洗澡的时候。大卫。是的。哇。
I mean, dishwashing liquid is pretty good. Wait, fourth and what? I lived on Ocean Park in second for years. Fourth between California and Washington. Yeah. Right by the stairs. That was my gym. I'd go to the stairs.
我是说，洗洁精相当不错。等等，第四街和什么？我多年来一直住在海洋公园和第二街。第四街，在加利福尼亚和华盛顿之间。是的。就在楼梯旁边。那是我的健身房。我会去楼梯。
I catered to a wedding at Anthony Edwards' house. When I just moved here and I was like, oh my God, it's the guy from ER and I'm in his kitchen. It was so wild. And then you were shooting pretty much next door to him when you guys were doing Will & Grace, right? It was crazy, yeah. Oh, my God.
我在安东尼·爱德华兹的房子里为一场婚礼提供餐饮。当我刚搬到这里时，我就像，哦，天哪，那是《急诊室的故事》里的那个人，我在他的厨房里。太疯狂了。然后你们在拍《威尔和格蕾丝》时，你们基本上就住在隔壁，对吧？太疯狂了，是的。哦，天哪。
And you did a lot, Shoney, you did a lot of commercials too back in that. Tons, yeah, it's the only way to pay the bills. We talked about, I remember you had those commercials that you were doing, like when Will and Grace was on, some of them came out. Yeah, I know. Yeah, isn't that where? Yeah. That was wild.
而且你做了很多，肖尼，你当时也做了很多广告。很多，是的，这是支付账单的唯一方法。我们谈过，我记得你当时做的那些广告，就像《威尔和格蕾丝》播出时，其中一些出来了。是的，我知道。是的，那不是吗？是的。那太疯狂了。
I had two commercials two on the Super Bowl in 1998. What were they? one was a bud light commercial i did a bud i did a bud light commercial oh really when 87 88 well you did miller light and bud light yeah michelope look at you no michleove and bud light i was all over the beers i was king of beers wait so david so when did you i mean because i was a i'm a big sci-fi nerd so so x yeah so x files how did that's what you're getting to right johnny how did that how did x files i know you're sick of talking about i know you And forgive us, forgive us, we're just fans.
我在1998年的超级碗上有两个广告。它们是什么？一个是百威淡啤广告，我做了一个百威，我做了一个百威淡啤广告。哦，真的吗？87年88年？嗯，你做了米勒淡啤和百威淡啤。是的，米凯洛。看看你。不，米凯洛和百威淡啤。我到处都是啤酒，我是啤酒之王。等等，所以大卫，所以你什么时候，我是说，因为我是一个，我是一个大科幻迷，所以，所以X，是的，所以X档案，它是怎么，这就是你要引出的，对吧，强尼，它是怎么，X档案，我知道你厌倦了谈论它，我知道你，请原谅我们，请原谅我们，我们只是粉丝。
I didn't ask. But I'm ready to listen. Jason read the books. Yeah, it was just an audition. And I remember at that point, I was not wanting to do television. You know, at that point, there was a real divide between television actors and movie actors, which has been erased in the past few years. or the past 20 years.
我没问。但我准备好听了。杰森读了书。是的，那只是一个试镜。我记得在那个时候，我不想做电视。你知道，在那个时候，电视演员和电影演员之间有真正的鸿沟，这在过去几年里已经被抹去了。或者过去20年。
So it was really, you know, I'm not a TV actor. That was my sense. Who was your North Star and film? Who did you want to be? Well, I mean, I didn't want to be Brando, but he was my North Star. Gotcha. Right.
所以这真的是，你知道，我不是电视演员。那是我的感觉。你在电影里的北极星是谁？你想成为谁？嗯，我是说，我不想成为白兰度，但他是我心中的北极星。明白了。没错。
Did you ever write any of the X-Files? Yeah, I did. You did? I wrote and directed two or three of them, yeah. One of them's a baseball one, Jason. I can't believe. I can't believe we haven't made this. I know.
你写过任何《X档案》吗？是的，我写过。你写过？我写并执导了两三集，是的。其中一集是棒球的，杰森。我不敢相信。我不敢相信我们还没拍这个。我知道。
we'll be right back and now back to the show so wait so you get this gig and and you sign you sign the five year or seven year standard thing before you go in and you test um so you know that if you get this you're stuck with something that you're not really kind of excited about then you get it was your yeah are you excited when you get it because of that yeah well you know you're not not excited to think it's going to go forever, which is a blessing when it does, but you get competitive, you know?
我们马上回来，现在回到节目。所以等等，所以你得到了这个工作，你签了五年或七年的标准合同，在你进去测试之前，嗯，所以你知道如果你得到了这个，你会被困在一些你并不是真正感到兴奋的事情上，然后你得到了，那是你的，是的，当你得到它时你兴奋吗，因为那个，是的，嗯，你知道，你不会不兴奋，认为它会永远持续下去，这是一种祝福，当它发生时，但你变得有竞争力，你知道吗？
You're just like, if I'm going to do it, I want it to win. I want it to go. You do the pilot, you want it to get picked up and get picked up. Yeah, sure, every step of the way. Then it gets well received and you're like, well, all right, now fucking TV star. Can I just stop for Tracy? Can I just say, so the testing process, so you don't know,
你只是觉得，如果我要做它，我想让它赢。我想让它继续。你拍了试播集，你希望它被选中并被选中。是的，当然，每一步都是。然后它受到了好评，你就想，好吧，现在是电视明星了。我可以为特蕾西停一下吗？我可以只说，所以测试过程，所以你不知道，
Jason just alluded to, and David knows, we all know, it used to be, I don't know if it still is the way, But what would happen is you'd go in for a show, whether it's X-Files or Will & Grace or whatever it is, and you'd get the audition and you'd go through and then you'd get a callback and you'd read for producers. Then what they do is they sort of take, for any given role, they might have three or four people
杰森刚才提到的，大卫知道，我们都知道，过去是，我不知道现在还是不是那样，但会发生的是，你会去参加一个节目，无论是《X档案》还是《威尔和格蕾丝》或其他什么，你会得到试镜，你会通过，然后你会得到回电，你会为制片人朗读。然后他们做的是，他们有点取，对于任何给定的角色，他们可能有三四个人
who they decide that they're going to, as they call it, bring to the network. Yeah. And that means they're kind of their select pick, three or four people for each role. And before you go and do this final audition, usually like in a conference room, something in an office building,
他们决定，正如他们所说的，带到电视网。是的。这意味着他们是他们精选的，每个角色三四个人。在你去进行最后一次试镜之前，通常是在会议室，办公楼里的某个地方，
the most uninspiring place you can imagine. Before you do that, for a day or two before, your agents in the show negotiate your contract, a five-year contract, and you sign it before you go in for the final audition, in the lobby. Right before you walk in.
你能想象到的最无聊的地方。在你做那个之前，提前一两天，你的经纪人在节目中协商你的合同，一份五年合同，你在去最后一次试镜之前签了它，在大厅里。就在你走进去之前。
So you got you. So you're broke, and then your agent goes, like, here's your contract. We've agreed you're going to get $25,000 an episode for the next five years. It's a lottery ticket. Yeah, and you're like, oh, my God, I'm so broke,
所以你有了你。所以你破产了，然后你的经纪人说，这是你的合同。我们已经同意你在接下来的五年里每集获得25,000美元。这是一张彩票。是的，你就像，哦，天哪，我太穷了，
and I'm going to get $25,000. an episode for the next five years and you're doing the math and you're like, and then I'm going to buy it, I'm going to buy a new car. And if you weren't nervous before, you're petrified now. And you sign it, and then you go, once you sign it, they take the signed, executed contract. So that you have no leverage if they give you the job.
而且我将在接下来的五年里每集获得25,000美元，你在做数学题，你就像，然后我要买它，我要买一辆新车。如果你之前不紧张，你现在被吓坏了。你签了它，然后你去，一旦你签了它，他们拿走签署的、执行的合同。这样如果他们给你这份工作，你就没有筹码了。
You go in and you then audition for all the execs at the network and then you're waiting and they decide whether or not you got the part. So. So nervous. They have you so over the barrel. You never realize you're never not over the barrel in that. in that process and it's really uninspiring and it's a very specific thing to get good at that to be able to block that part of it out to then go and deliver at the final moment it's you're you're
你进去，然后为电视网的所有高管试镜，然后你等着，他们决定你是否得到了这个角色。所以。太紧张了。他们让你在那个过程中完全被拿捏。你从来没有意识到你在这个过程中从来没有不被拿捏，这真的很无聊，而且要擅长那个，能够把那部分屏蔽掉，然后在最后时刻交付，这是你，你
kind of torture yeah you're fighting out of a hole right what if after that david was like it was an offer but anyway it wasn't it wasn't an offer so so so david so david your process is you're kind of you're a little conflicted about doing a tv series but you want to do and it's a great great paycheck. So you go in and you sign the contract, you do the test. Now you, and then you do the pilot, right? And so now they've got the executed thing. And then the network, sorry, again, for Tracy, then they decide from all their pilots what shows are going to make it on the air next year. So you're waiting for a month or two for that. And then they go, great, your show is happening, you're in it, and we've got you for five years. And then what happens a lot
有点折磨，是的，你在从洞里爬出来，对吧？如果在那之后大卫就像，这是一个提议，但无论如何，它不是，它不是一个提议。所以，所以，所以大卫，所以大卫，你的过程是，你有点矛盾关于做电视剧，但你想做，这是一个很棒的薪水。所以你进去签了合同，你做了测试。现在你，然后你做了试播集，对吧？所以现在他们有了执行的东西。然后电视网，抱歉，再次，为了特蕾西，然后他们决定从他们所有的试播集中，明年哪些节目会播出。所以你要等一两个月。然后他们说，太棒了，你的节目正在进行，你在里面，我们签了你五年。然后经常发生的是
is you go, oh my God, this is so great. I'm going to make $20,000 or $25,000 an episode. And then two years in, if you're lucky enough that it's going, you're like, hey, man, I deserve way more than 20. I got to get out of here. I got to stay available for all the feature opportunities I think are out there waiting for. David, so you know that process, right? So you're there, and you're doing X-Files, and you guys come out of the gate pretty hot. It's a, it's kind of a hit. Am I right or wrong? It's a hit on Fox. And if you can remember that far back, Fox was really, like, not a real network at that point. It just started. There's like 93 when you guys?
你走，哦，天哪，这太棒了。我每集要赚20,000或25,000美元。然后两年后，如果你足够幸运它还在继续，你就像，嘿，伙计，我值得比20多得多。我得离开这里。我得保持空闲，为了我认为在那里等待的所有电影机会。大卫，所以你知道那个过程，对吧？所以你在那里，你在做《X档案》，你们开局相当火爆。这是一个，它有点像一个热门。我是对还是错？它是福克斯的一个热门。如果你能记得那么远，福克斯在那个时候真的，就像，不是一个真正的电视网。它才刚刚开始。那是93年当你们？
They didn't have programming, you know, across the board all day long, really. And, you know, they had married with children and I can't remember, you know, they had made 9-0-2-1-0. Tracy Allman. Yeah, that's right. But they're really in the upstart network. They didn't have a big drama kind of like you guys. No, not at all. And we didn't need to get like huge numbers to be a hit for Fox, which was nice because we, Fox wasn't even in all the homes.
他们没有节目，你知道，全天候，真的。而且，你知道，他们有《奉子成婚》和我记不清了，你知道，他们拍了《飞越比弗利》。特蕾西·厄尔曼。是的，没错。但他们真的是初创电视网。他们没有像你们那样的大剧。不，一点也不。而且我们不需要获得巨大的数字就能成为福克斯的热门，这很好，因为我们，福克斯甚至没有进入所有家庭。
Who was running Fox at the time when you guys were there? Do you remember? Who was running it? Garthansier? Who? Was it Garthansa? He was at NBC, I think. Yeah, he was one of the starters of Fox.
你们在那里时是谁在经营福克斯？你记得吗？谁在经营它？加斯·安西尔？谁？是加斯·安萨吗？我想他在NBC。是的，他是福克斯的创始人之一。
Yeah, I can't believe you remember that name, Jay. Or was it WB? He didn't want me for a gig, and I had to re-audition. You ready for this? For my buddy Michael Malley's show, we did the pilot. I get the pilot. We do it. We shoot it.
是的，我不敢相信你记得那个名字，杰。还是WB？他不想让我参加一个演出，我不得不重新试镜。你准备好这个了吗？为了我哥们迈克尔·马利的节目，我们拍了试播集。我得到了试播集。我们做了。我们拍了它。
It gets picked up to series, and then he didn't want me. And I had to go back. Sandy Grush out. Two months later. It might have been Sandy. I had to go back two months later and re-audition for a part and do a scene in a conference room, a scene holding up pages that I had already filmed that existed on film to get my job.
它被选中成为系列剧，然后他不想让我。我不得不回去。桑迪·格鲁什奥。两个月后。可能是桑迪。我不得不回去两个月后，为一个角色重新试镜，并在会议室里做一个场景，一个拿着我已经在电影中拍摄过的、存在于胶片上的页面的场景，来得到我的工作。
Terrible. That's crazy. In a conference room in Burbank. That's crazy. Wait, you don't need to see me do this in the room. Do you remember what year that was, Will? 1999. That's when I first met you.
太可怕了。太疯狂了。在伯班克的会议室里。太疯狂了。等等，你不需要看我在房间里做这个。你记得那是哪一年吗，威尔？1999年。那是我第一次见到你。
Yeah. I met you at the upfriends. Yeah, that year. That's right. All the upfronts. Did you get it, Will? I did actually, yeah. Again.
是的。我在Upfronts见到你。是的，那一年。没错。所有的Upfronts。你得到了吗，威尔？我确实得到了，是的。再一次。
Well done. I got it again. You imitated yourself. What a fucking victory. Do you think I had, I think I count it. I think I had a thousand beers that night. That's not enough. That's not enough for that.
干得好。我又得到了。你模仿了你自己。真是个该死的胜利。你觉得我有，我想我数了。我想那天晚上我喝了一千杯啤酒。那还不够。那还不够那个。
Wait, David, were you a sci-fi fan when you got it? No. And are you now? Not at all. No. Wow, how about that? No, not really. So you get X-Files.
等等，大卫，你得到它时是科幻迷吗？不。你现在是吗？一点也不。不。哇，那怎么样？不，不是真的。所以你得到了《X档案》。
You go up to Vancouver. You guys start doing it. It's a hit for Fox. And then it really starts to, when's the moment you can feel that it's kind of pushed through to the general... Probably like the third. year just globally it felt just huge you know i mean it was it was a global hit yeah massive how did you
你去了温哥华。你们开始做它。它是福克斯的一个热门。然后它真的开始，什么时候是你感觉到它有点推向大众的时刻……大概是第三年，全球范围内感觉非常巨大，你知道，我的意思是，它是一个全球热门，是的，巨大的。你怎么样
like relocating up into vancouver for so long well i loved it at first yeah um because i didn't really have any roots in los angeles you know i just uh i i'd come here to try to get work um and you weren't going to the blow up doll wasn't going to start crying i mean they they can perform a lot of duties but tears are not one I'm not going to speak for her she Jesus Christ but I will tell you
喜欢搬到温哥华那么久吗？嗯，起初我很喜欢，是的，嗯，因为我在洛杉矶真的没有任何根基，你知道，我只是，我来这里是为了尝试找工作，而且你不会，充气娃娃不会开始哭泣，我的意思是，它们可以执行很多职责，但眼泪不是其中之一。我不会替她说话，她，耶稣基督，但我会告诉你
so I hear this is what I hear this is we hear yeah oh my God so I you know I don't know how you guys feel about Vancouver
所以我听到，这就是我听到的，这是我们听到的，是的，哦，天哪，所以我，你知道，我不知道你们对温哥华感觉如何
but it's a beautiful part of the world and I've never been you've never been I've never been I want to go so bad how is that possible it's the greatest
但它是世界上美丽的一部分，我从来没去过。你从来没去过？我从来没去过。我太想去了。这怎么可能？它是最棒的
it's so beautiful so I loved it And, yeah, I didn't mind being out of L.A. at all. Yeah. I just loved being up there. And in a way, we got to just focus on doing the work. There wasn't any kind of L.A. around us. There wasn't any kind of whatever heat that was happening.
它太美了，所以我很喜欢它。而且，是的，我一点也不介意离开洛杉矶。是的。我只是喜欢待在那里。在某种程度上，我们只需要专注于工作。我们周围没有任何洛杉矶的东西。没有任何正在发生的热度。
We were kind of cut off from in a really good way. And in many ways, it was my education as an actor, having to go to work every damn day for 14 hours. I mean, these were really long days. And I really taught myself how to act. How soon into the run of it and the success of it did you start thinking, all right, good here, ready to move on and maybe parlay some of this into, you know, what did you have your eyes on?
我们以一种非常好的方式与它隔绝了。在很多方面，这是我作为演员的教育，不得不每天该死地去工作14个小时。我的意思是，这些日子真的很长。我真的教会了自己如何演戏。在它运行和成功多久之后，你开始想，好吧，这里很好，准备好继续前进，也许把其中的一些转化为，你知道，你盯着什么？
Was it still features? Yeah, I mean, that was really, you know, I had that kind of bias, you know, that was kind of baked in from a young age. You know, the TV shows that I watched when I was a kid that was quantitatively different. the acting in it you know that it's not the way now but you you you so i just remember the the the you you had very much a um a movie um style of acting in other words you you're very subtle
还是电影吗？是的，我的意思是，那真的是，你知道，我有那种偏见，你知道，那是从小就根深蒂固的。你知道，我小时候看的电视节目，在数量上是不同的。里面的表演，你知道，现在不是那样了，但你，你，所以我只记得，你，你非常有，嗯，电影风格的表演，换句话说，你非常微妙
well that's how i would not get that's why i didn't get i would audition and not get any roles in television right i would say he's a he's a movie star and i was like well fuck i can't i don't have a pot to piss in either so can you get good that you didn't can i please play puppet man, can I get that part? David, I want to ask you about time management because you're a musician. You literally write novels, which is amazing. You act, you do some other stuff, I'm sure you haven't mentioned.
嗯，那就是我不会得到，这就是为什么我没有得到，我会试镜，在电视上得不到任何角色，对吧？我会说他是一个电影明星，而我就像，好吧，该死，我也没有钱，所以你能变好吗，你没有，我可以请演木偶人吗，我可以得到那个角色吗？大卫，我想问你关于时间管理的问题，因为你是一名音乐家。你真的写小说，这太棒了。你演戏，你做其他一些事情，我肯定你还没提到。
Do some other stuff. How do you manage all of that on a daily basis or weekly or monthly or whatever? Do you pick a priority that you focus on or do you splice it? Whatever's like in front of me is what I'll do. songwriting can happen at any time pick up a guitar but with writing a novel everything has to stop and i have to work on that for a few months i write really fast and and but it's an intense experience of like eight hour days doing that and then of course i can't write when i'm acting
做其他一些事情。你每天或每周或每月或无论如何是如何管理所有这些的？你选择一个你关注的优先级，还是你把它拼接起来？无论什么在我面前，我就会做什么。写歌可以在任何时候发生，拿起吉他，但写小说，一切都必须停止，我必须在那上面工作几个月。我写得非常快，而且，但这是一种强烈的体验，比如八小时的工作日，然后当然，我演戏时不能写
i can't write when i'm directing um so that do you have a do you have a a goal in your in your mind that is louder than all the other goals and that then informs how you allocate your time that's probably the problem that I have is I don't really have a goal except to satisfy some kind of itch or and that's a daily itch not a weekly or a monthly or no it's a lifelong kind of a thing it's just for instance like I want to make a series out of one of the novels that I've written and that's that's really my greatest ambition at this point but there's there's also a movie I'm shooting in February that I wrote but I'm not directing I'm just acting in so you've got a new series area now. I think that we're November.
我执导时不能写，嗯，所以你有一个，你有一个目标在你的脑海里，比所有其他目标都响亮，然后这决定了你如何分配你的时间吗？那可能是我有的问题，我真的没有目标，除了满足某种痒，或者，那是一个日常的痒，不是每周或每月或不，这是一个终身的某种东西。这只是，例如，我想把我写的小说之一拍成系列剧，那真的是我目前最大的野心。但还有一部电影，我二月份要拍，我写的，但我不是导演，我只是在演戏。所以你现在有一个新的系列领域。我想我们是十一月。
Right. Yeah. Oh, really? Hey, thanks for not having me on the live show. I mean... Dude, that's for movie stars, bro. I'm pretty good on my feet. Yeah, malice. It's Amazon. I'm not sure November 3rd or something like that.
没错。是的。哦，真的吗？嘿，谢谢没让我上直播节目。我的意思是……伙计，那是给电影明星的，兄弟。我临场发挥还不错。是的，恶意。它是亚马逊。我不确定是11月3日还是什么的。
What's it called again? Malice. Malice. Okay. Yeah, it's coming in November on Amazon. And by the way, David, we'll get you a seat to one of the... We have these new stage seats that we're going to do on the live show. I was listening. I was listening.
它叫什么名字？恶意。恶意。好的。是的，它十一月在亚马逊上播出。顺便说一句，大卫，我们会给你一个座位，去其中一个……我们有这些新的舞台座位，我们要在直播节目中做。我在听。我在听。
But, you know, if I was wondering to this, we've had people on who have been part of something that sort of really struck a chord, you know, culturally, the pieces, as Sean would say, IP, but part of, X-Files, obviously, over a number of years, you know, had this, has this intense following and had a, and I was one of the followers. I used to watch it religiously back in the 90s.
但是，你知道，如果我对此感到好奇，我们有参与过真正引起共鸣的人，你知道，在文化上，这些作品，正如肖恩所说的，IP，但部分，X档案，显然，多年来，你知道，有这个，有这个强烈的追随者，并且有一个，我是追随者之一。我过去在90年代虔诚地看它。
And I saw the film, I saw the first film, I didn't see the second film. The first film was a big hit. Do you, is there, that thing when you run into people who are big fans of it, do you ever feel a response, weirdly? I'm just, like, a responsibility as the sort of the, as the caretaker of that thing of X-Files,
我看了电影，我看了第一部电影，我没看第二部电影。第一部电影是一个大热门。你，有没有，当你遇到那些大粉丝时，你有没有感觉到一种回应，奇怪地？我只是，就像，一种责任，作为那种，作为X档案的看护人，
does that, I don't want to say there's a burden, but like, you're the guy, you're the front-facing face person of the X-laws. Do you feel that, yeah? Well, of course there was a time when I wanted to leave it behind, you know, and reinvent myself. But then over the years, you begin to, respect the kind of power of the show and the size of the show. And the meaning that it has for people, you know, at first when you're younger, you think, oh, it's not because of me, but it's personal.
那个，我不想说这是一种负担，但就像，你是那个人，你是X档案的门面人物。你感觉到那个，是的？嗯，当然有一段时间我想把它抛在脑后，你知道，重塑自己。但后来多年来，你开始，尊重那种节目的力量和节目的规模。以及它对人们的意义，你知道，起初当你年轻时，你认为，哦，这不是因为我，但它是私人的。
And then you realize it's not personal. It's just that this thing has a place in people's lives and I represent that to them. And I'm an asshole if I don't respect that. I say that all the time. About you? No, I'm kidding. No, I do say that all the time. I said it before I here where you become famous for playing a certain role or in a movie or whatever it is. And then you spend several years trying to distance yourself that because you want to be able to play all these things. And in doing so, you alienate the fans that made you, kind of, because they are in love with you because of the thing that you just said, that you made them feel.
然后你意识到它不是私人的。只是这个东西在人们的生活中占有一席之地，我代表了他们。如果我不尊重这一点，我就是个混蛋。我一直这么说。关于你？不，我在开玩笑。不，我确实一直这么说。我在来这里之前说过，你因为扮演某个角色或在电影中或无论它是什么而变得出名。然后你花几年时间试图与那个保持距离，因为你想能够扮演所有这些东西。而在这样做时，你疏远了成就你的粉丝，因为他们爱你是为了你刚才说的那个东西，你让他们感受到的。
and you're doing a disservice and I always say that I'm an asshole if I don't embrace the character Jack from Will & Grace and what it did for so many people and all that character is that exactly
而你是在做坏事，我总是说如果我不拥抱《威尔和格蕾丝》里的杰克这个角色，以及它为那么多人所做的一切，以及那个角色所代表的一切，我就是个混蛋，那正是
exactly you know and you're also depriving yourself the treat that you deserve which is like how lucky how rare it is to be a part of something that holds a spot for a real that's exactly it is rare and you get old enough to
完全正确，你知道，而且你也在剥夺自己应得的款待，那就是，多么幸运，多么罕见，能成为某件为现实保留位置的事情的一部分，那正是，它是罕见的，你老到
appreciate that you know that you got to do something that was that was great, that did strike a chord with people. And when you're young, you don't think like that. It takes a few years to go, oh, I need to appreciate that more, you know. No, it's funny. I read somebody, I made the mistake, David, of reading a comment a while ago, somebody saying, like, he thinks that he doesn't,
欣赏这一点，你知道，你做了一些伟大的事情，确实引起了人们的共鸣。当你年轻时，你不会那样想。需要几年时间才能说，哦，我需要更多地欣赏这一点，你知道。不，这很有趣。我读到某人，我犯了一个错误，大卫，前段时间读了一条评论，有人说，就像，他认为他没有，
that he should have had more of a thing or whatever about me. And I was like, no, motherfucker, I'm so grateful for any time that I was able to do anything that even anybody liked for a moment. What a joke. Yeah, right. Yeah, and I'm a guy, I don't even have my high school diploma. Like, the fact that I'm still like going to stop bragging. The world doesn't owe me a living.
他应该有更多关于我的东西或什么的。而我就像，不，混蛋，我非常感谢任何时候我能够做任何甚至有人喜欢片刻的事情。真是个笑话。是的，没错。是的，我是一个人，我甚至没有我的高中毕业证书。就像，事实上我还在，停止吹牛。世界不欠我生活。
We're so lucky that we've been able to do this at all. That's so not the way I think about it. Now, I'd like to ask a question that Sean's too shy to ask. Did you ever learn anything doing the X-Files? It gives you any sort of confidence that we are not alone. And Sean promises not to tell anybody if you could just tell us. It's just us for talking. I never learned anything, no
我们很幸运，我们能够做这件事。那根本不是我思考它的方式。现在，我想问一个肖恩太害羞而不敢问的问题。你在做《X档案》时学到了什么吗？它给了你任何关于我们并不孤单的信心吗？肖恩承诺如果你能告诉我们，他不会告诉任何人。这只是我们在这里谈话。我什么也没学到，不
but I have the same kind of sense as when I went into it which is it seems to me that the impossibility would be that we are the only sentient life. I mean there's just too many galaxies too many planets, too many Goldilocks planets so the odds
但我有和我进入它时一样的感觉，那就是，在我看来，不可能的是我们是唯一的感知生命。我的意思是，有太多的星系，太多的行星，太多的宜居行星，所以几率
to me are slanted way in favor of the existence of extraterraces whether or not we haven't we haven't advanced technologically enough to reach out to them and they might be all around us and we just don't have the technology to see it right they don't want us to
对我来说，严重偏向于外星生命的存在，无论我们是否，我们还没有在技术上足够先进到去接触他们，他们可能就在我们周围，我们只是没有技术看到它，对吧？他们不想让我们
they're they're I always think look at it you know when you see all these things these congressional hearings and stuff about pilots you run into these shapes or things that are moving in ways that we can understand I always think I was thinking oh we're so dumb we think that they want to that we need to connect and they're like no no no
他们，他们，我总是想看看它，你知道，当你看到所有这些国会听证会和关于飞行员遇到这些形状或正在以我们能理解的方式移动的东西的事情时，我总是想，我当时在想，哦，我们太笨了，我们认为他们想要，我们需要连接，而他们就像，不，不，不
you guys we're good we're good yeah we're good we're watching you we're just watching you guys just want to have anything to do you. Ripping over yourself like a bunch of ding-dongs. Didn't we have, we had a guy on once. Oh, yeah. And I'm paraphrasing here, but he said something that was really sort of interesting
你们，我们很好，我们很好，是的，我们很好，我们在看着你们，我们只是在看着你们，你们只是不想和你们有任何关系。像一群傻瓜一样在自己身上撕扯。我们不是有一次有一个人吗？哦，是的。我在这里转述，但他说了些非常有趣的事情
that it makes a lot of sense to me, that perhaps they are all around us in a way that we can't see just like our cell phone service or radio waves, you know, from like television with rubberty or whatever, it's just flying all around. You don't see any of that, that, that, that, that. all the ones and zeros of whatever the hell it is that fly around that make our phones. They could be all in that stuff. Yeah, they live in the space between the space.
这对我来说很有意义，也许他们以一种我们看不见的方式就在我们周围，就像我们的手机服务或无线电波，你知道，来自电视的，无论什么，它只是在到处飞。你看不到任何那个，那个，那个，那个，那个。所有那些飞来飞去构成我们手机的1和0。他们可能都在那些东西里。是的，他们生活在空间之间的空间里。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. The dark matter. I used to say this thing with, are you aware of like the phenomenon of like a ship of fools? Do you remember that from the Middle Ages where... I think it was a great Robert Plant song, is that? Is it? Is it?
是的，是的，是的。暗物质。我过去常说这个，你意识到像愚人船那样的现象吗？你记得中世纪的那个吗……我想那是一首很棒的罗伯特·普兰特的歌，是吗？是吗？是吗？
It could be. But the idea was that they would take their deviance and criminals, they're incorrigible criminals. And they'd put them on a ship, you know, because they didn't have space for them. They'd just put them on a ship out to sea. Floating Australia. Sometimes, well, sometimes, you know, you'd encounter a ship of fools, and it wasn't a fun thing, right?
可能是。但这个想法是，他们会把他们的越轨者和罪犯，他们是不可救药的罪犯。他们会把他们放在一艘船上，你知道，因为他们没有空间放他们。他们只是把他们放在一艘船上出海。漂浮的澳大利亚。有时，嗯，有时，你知道，你会遇到一艘愚人船，那不是一件有趣的事情，对吧？
Right. Well, they weren't armed. They shouldn't be armed. No, no, they made sure they were armed. But my theory about because so much of alien abduction testimony has to do with being probed anally and having their teeth drilled. my theory was that alien civilizations were putting their deviance and dentists
没错。嗯，他们没有武装。他们不应该被武装。不，不，他们确保他们被武装了。但关于因为太多的外星人绑架证词与被肛门探测和牙齿被钻有关，我的理论是外星文明正在把他们的越轨者和牙医
on a ship. Oh, I see. I'm sending it out into the galaxy and somehow they've come in Darien. We can cut this, we can cut this, but why are aliens so obsessed with anal? Okay, so. Why would you want to cut that? I don't want to offend,
在船上。哦，我明白了。我把它发向银河系，不知怎么的，他们就来到了达里恩。我们可以剪掉这段，我们可以剪掉这段，但为什么外星人对肛门那么着迷？好吧，那么。你为什么要剪掉那段？我不想冒犯，
don't want to get any comments from an ad. David, what do you do, so if you're not reading and you're not writing and you're not writing music, and writing screenplays and doing all this stuff. What is, this is sort of the Sean question that it has, what do you do in, is there anything you do in your downtime that you're like, what's your guilty pleasure?
不想收到任何广告评论。大卫，你是做什么的？如果你不读书、不写作、不写音乐、不写剧本，也不做这些事。那么，这是肖恩的问题，你在空闲时间会做什么？你有什么罪恶的快感吗？
We'd be surprised to learn. What do you do in the space between the space? Is it gardening? Nice. Anything dumb that you do, you go like, oh, man, I'd be embarrassed if people knew I did this stupid thing. I don't really. I'm, I'm, I'm so bad with hobbies. I really should have a hobby.
我们可能会感到惊讶。你在空隙时间里做什么？是园艺吗？不错。你有没有做过什么傻事，让你觉得，哦，天哪，如果别人知道我做了这件蠢事，我会很尴尬。我真的没有。我，我，我非常不擅长培养爱好。我真的应该有个爱好。
Not one. It's really a problem. Well, you have, do you do 25,000 things. It's really a problem. Are you playing basketball? You're playing golf from the cross-country skiing? I wish I was playing basketball. Yeah.
一个都没有。这真是个问题。好吧，你做了25000件事。这真是个问题。你在打篮球吗？你在打高尔夫球还是越野滑雪？我希望我在打篮球。是的。
No, now I feel bad. I do it in a hobby. And when people like me, when dummies like me are watching television, you're reading, so you're not watching any like? No, no. I watch TV. I'm watching Black Rabbit. Come on. Oh, yeah.
不，现在我感到难过了。我有爱好。当像我这样的人，当像我这样的笨蛋在看电视时，你在读书，所以你什么都不看吗？不，不。我看电视。我在看《黑兔》。拜托。哦，是的。
Black Rabbit airing now on Netflix, starring Jason and J-Bla. Production from Aggregate Films brings you Black Rabbit. Two brothers. So it's not like you're not watching below deck or anything like that. No, but I do watch, I'll watch a Love Island. Sure, you do. But then I realize 45 hours. Yeah.
《黑兔》正在Netflix播出，由杰森和J-Bla主演。Aggregate Films制作公司为您带来《黑兔》。两兄弟。所以并不是说你不看《甲板之下》之类的节目。不，但我确实看，我会看《恋爱岛》。当然，你会看。但我意识到有45个小时。是的。
I mean, it's not like a 15-hour season. No. Somehow they make 45 fucking hours out of that nonsense. But so you watch baseball, is that your number one sport to watch? Basketball is probably not my name. Basketball. I hear the Lakers are going to be good this year. That it could be.
我的意思是，这不像是一个15小时的剧集。不。不知何故，他们从那堆废话里搞出了45个小时。但你既然看棒球，那是你最喜欢看的运动吗？篮球可能不是我的首选。篮球。我听说湖人队今年会很强。那倒有可能。
Okay. Who's your team? Next? Oh, the next. Yeah. Now, you're not in New York. Now, where do you live? I live in, I live in L.A.
好的。你是哪支球队的粉丝？尼克斯队？哦，尼克斯队。是的。现在，你不在纽约。那么，你住在哪里？我住在，我住在洛杉矶。
Okay. Why the next? Because I grew up in New York. No. That's just... Were you not awake when we started the podcast? Well, there was, there was some doll fucking and stuff like that, but that just put you in kind of a state. You figured that was just like an hourly thing that you were doing in New York.
好的。为什么是尼克斯队？因为我在纽约长大。不。那只是……我们开始播客时你没醒吗？好吧，当时有一些玩偶性行为之类的东西，但这只是让你处于某种状态。你以为那只是你在纽约时每小时都会做的事情。
That ball was going to stay with you, huh? How are we going to say? This is terrible. I'm just glad he's not alive. What if the next time we watch Jason on TV at the Dodgers game is sitting next to a blow-up time? He was the other day.
那个球会一直跟着你，是吗？我们要怎么说？这太糟糕了。我很高兴他还活着。如果下次我们在电视上看到杰森在道奇队的比赛中坐在一个充气娃娃旁边会怎样？他那天就是这样。
With an X-Files t-shirt up. Wait, David, I have an idea for you. Okay. Come on. So because you write novels and you're not a sci-fi thing, you want to sell a lot of copies or something. Do like, you know,
穿着一件《X档案》的T恤。等等，大卫，我有个主意。好的。来吧。因为你写小说，而且你不是科幻迷，你想多卖点书什么的。做点，你知道的，
Bucky Funk fucking Dent was baseball-adjacent. Do whatever you do brilliantly and just make a little sci-fi-adjacent thing. Just a little bit. right well well this is well that episode of uh of the ex-files that i wrote and directed that i want jason to watch because it's called the unnatural and it's a baseball oh i like that all right so you'll have to i i did that uh will for brimley do a cameo on that at all no but uh wilford brimmy at walsh wow wow that's pretty that's it that's wilfr grimly adjacent yeah i love m m at walsh by the way
《巴基·登特》是棒球题材的。做任何你擅长的事情，然后加一点科幻元素。就一点点。好吧，好吧，我写并导演的那集《X档案》，我想让杰森看，因为它叫《非自然》，是一个棒球……哦，我喜欢那个。好吧，所以你得……我确实做了那个……威尔福德·布里姆利在里面客串了吗？没有，但是威尔福德·布里姆利在《沃尔什》里……哇，哇，那真是……那是威尔福德·布里姆利相关的，是的，我顺便说一句，我很喜欢《沃尔什》。
It just is a quick aside. Yeah, he was fantastic. And he, uh, did he give you a $2 bill? He didn't. No, he does that, he does that with a lot of, or did. I had one. Then we just made David feel bad again. This is, this is before $2 bills were being made.
这只是个简短的题外话。是的，他太棒了。而且他，呃，他给了你一张2美元的钞票吗？他没有。不，他确实对很多人这样做，或者曾经这样做过。我有一张。然后我们又让大卫感到难过了。这是在2美元钞票开始发行之前的事。
It's not hard to make me feel bad. But, um, he replaced an actor who got ill. Um, so he was a, he was a, he had short notice. And it was a lot of dialogue. His, his character, was really the exposition man in this episode. And at one point, he turned to me, because I only think he had a couple days with the script.
让我感到难过并不难。但是，嗯，他代替了一位生病的演员。嗯，所以他是一个，他是一个，他接到的通知很短。而且台词很多。他的角色，在这一集中确实是负责解释剧情的人。有一次，他转向我，因为我觉得他只有几天时间看剧本。
He got, you know, and he said, this isn't writing, it's typing. I was like, well, I did the typing. And at one point, he fucked up. It was so great. Instead of calling me Agent Mulder, he called me Agent McIver. And I kept it in. There you go.
他，你知道的，他说，这不是写作，这是打字。我说，好吧，我做了打字的工作。有一次，他搞砸了。太棒了。他没有叫我穆德探员，而是叫我麦基弗探员。我把它保留了下来。你看。
Did you really? Oh, yeah. It was too good. That guy was so good. I just remember, what was the one he did with Michael Keaton? No, you know, the great cleaning sober. And he was also in Fletch. He was the doctor in Fletch.
你真的保留了吗？哦，是的。太棒了。那家伙太棒了。我只记得，他和迈克尔·基顿演的那部是什么？不，你知道的，伟大的《清洁工》。而且他还演了《古灵精探》。他是《古灵精探》里的医生。
He was a fantastic. Yeah, he was a fantastic guy. David, you're fantastic. You're fantastic, David. We've gone over. We rarely go over. We've gone over with you because we love talking to you. So, malice is out, Amazon Prime,
他是一个了不起的人。是的，他是一个了不起的人。大卫，你太棒了。你太棒了，大卫。我们超时了。我们很少超时。我们和你超时了，因为我们喜欢和你聊天。所以，《恶意》已经在亚马逊Prime上线了，
we'd be remiss if we didn't mention that again. Mm-hmm. Yes. And we've got a ton of... Can I plug Black Rabbit again? Should I do that? Please. Yeah.
如果我们不再次提到它，那将是我们的失职。嗯哼。是的。而且我们有很多……我可以再宣传一下《黑兔》吗？我应该这样做吗？请便。是的。
What service is that on? And we have to... Where do we find that? Very, very nice of you to share some of your time with us, sir. Yeah, I'm so glad we did this. I'm so glad. What a joy. Thank you for coming on.
那是在什么服务平台上？我们必须……我们在哪里可以找到它？非常，非常感谢您与我们分享您的时间，先生。是的，我很高兴我们做了这个。我很高兴。真是太愉快了。谢谢你来参加。
And thank you. Thanks for having me. You guys are great. Thank you, Dan. Actor, writer, screenwriter, novelist, It's an all-around, great guy. David Duke Covney, thank you so much, David, for your time. Thank you.
也谢谢你。谢谢你们邀请我。你们太棒了。谢谢，丹。演员、作家、编剧、小说家，这是一个全能的、很棒的人。大卫·杜楚尼，非常感谢你，大卫，感谢你的时间。谢谢。
It's been enjoying having you. Thank you, David. Thanks, David. All right, bye, bye, bud. Double D. Double-D comes to the Smartless Studio, I guess, is what this is. Yeah. Welcome to the Smartless Studio.
很高兴有你参与。谢谢你，大卫。谢谢，大卫。好的，再见，伙计。双D。双D来到了Smartless工作室，我想这就是这里。是的。欢迎来到Smartless工作室。
Yeah. Smartless is shot in front of a live studio audience. He's real slick and cool. He's just, well, he's kind of. Always has been. When you're smart, you're confident. He's very confident. Yeah.
是的。Smartless是在现场观众面前录制的。他真的很圆滑很酷。他只是，嗯，他有点。一直都是这样。当你聪明时，你就会自信。他非常自信。是的。
I didn't know half that stuff. That's amazing. Because you're not smart. You're not smart. It's true. I mean, it is true. I mean, think about it. He graduated, like, head of his class in high school.
我不知道那一半的事情。太神奇了。因为你不聪明。你不聪明。这是真的。我的意思是，这是真的。我的意思是，想想看。他高中时以班级第一名的成绩毕业。
And then he goes to Princeton. Then he goes to Yale. And he gets a master's in English literature. And then he starts to work on his PhD. And while he's working on his PhD, he's like, It's a mickleup spot. Yeah, I want to go to start doing some acting lessons, just to sort of see how that is.
然后他去了普林斯顿。然后他去了耶鲁。他获得了英语文学硕士学位。然后他开始攻读博士学位。当他在攻读博士学位时，他想，这是一个很棒的转折点。是的，我想去开始做一些表演课程，只是为了看看那是怎么回事。
Yeah, I mean. Well, wait. Could you imagine being his parents? You're like, oh, boy, baby, we hit the lot of. Look at this kid. We can't wait to brag about this with our friend, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then they go see his first job. And he's becoming an actor.
是的，我的意思是。好吧，等等。你能想象做他的父母吗？你会想，哦，天哪，宝贝，我们中大奖了。看看这个孩子。我们迫不及待地想和我们的朋友吹嘘这个，等等等等。然后他们去看了他的第一份工作。他成了一名演员。
And he's fucking this goddamn inflatable. Yeah. Well, I mean, there's nothing more disappointing than just going. I want to be an actor. And you're like, oh, Christ. All right. Maybe he's good. Hopefully he's good.
而且他在和这个该死的充气娃娃……是的。好吧，我的意思是，没有什么比去说“我想成为一名演员”更令人失望的了。你会想，哦，天哪。好吧。也许他很擅长。希望他很擅长。
And then they go see his banging this doll. I know. No. But he's, he landed on his feet. He did. You know? Boy, did he ever. Did he ever?
然后他们去看了他正在和那个玩偶发生关系。我知道。不。但他，他站稳了脚跟。他做到了。你知道吗？天哪，他确实做到了。他真的做到了吗？
street a few times yeah he's such a we didn't even get into californication we just he's just done so much god he did some movies too he did a bunch of movies and he's just got this new show new show called malice malice what do you think it's about what do i think what do you think malice is about is it about is about is about a guy's girlfriend who and her name is alice and it's like it's like it's like it's like it's like it's about is about is about is about a guy's girlfriend who and her name is Alice and it's it's M apostrophe Alice Oh oh my Alice
街上几次，是的，他真是……我们甚至还没谈到《加州靡情》，他只是做了太多事，天哪，他还拍了一些电影，他拍了一堆电影，他刚有了这个新节目，新节目叫《恶意》，《恶意》，你觉得它是关于什么的？我怎么想？你觉得《恶意》是关于什么的？是关于一个男人的女朋友，她的名字叫爱丽丝，它就像是……它是关于一个男人的女朋友，她的名字叫爱丽丝，它是M撇号爱丽丝，哦，哦，我的爱丽丝。
Yeah No this is my Alice This is my Alice This is my Alice Yeah Maybe it's about that It could be Just to throw everybody off
是的，不，这是我的爱丽丝，这是我的爱丽丝，这是我的爱丽丝，是的，也许是关于那个，这很有可能，只是为了迷惑大家。
Right don't we too Yeah Well Bennett suggests This is I'm calling Jason you said he landed on his feet maybe on his bipartite
对，我们不是吗？是的，好吧，贝内特建议，这是……我叫杰森，你说他站稳了脚跟，也许是在他的籽骨上。
sesamoids which is what is it the symptoms and treatment options are it's from the Melbourne podiatrist no
籽骨，那是什么？症状和治疗方案是来自墨尔本足病医生，不。
you're not going to take bipartite no no no no have you have you by the way have you seen the new show
你不会接受籽骨的，不，不，不，顺便问一下，你看过那个新节目了吗？
have you seen the new show by chance by no no We're not changing that. How are you doing that? How are you overruling with that? With just like a...
你碰巧看过那个新节目了吗？不，不，我们不会改变那个。你是怎么做到的？你是怎么用那个来否决的？就用一个……
I tried to tee you guys up with, you know, what do you think malice is about? I thought maybe one of you ding-dongs had a bio. Oh, you know, well, I thought maybe it said, is it a biopic? About it, guys. Girlfriend named Alice. Whose whistle was that?
我试着给你们抛出话题，你知道，你觉得《恶意》是关于什么的？我以为你们这些笨蛋中可能有人看过简介。哦，你知道，好吧，我以为它说，这是一部传记片吗？关于一个男人的女朋友叫爱丽丝。那是谁的口哨声？
Who did the whistle? That's great. That's really good. Oh, we got to start. adding the whistle. Yeah. Smartless. Smartless.
谁吹的口哨？太棒了。那真的很好。哦，我们得开始加上口哨声了。是的。Smartless。Smartless。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless是100%有机的，由Rob Armjarf、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry手工制作。Smartless。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。